hey guys hack exploit here and in this
video we're gonna get started with the
web application penetration testing
series alright so a lot of you guys have
been asking for this mostly because you
want to learn the art of bug bounty and
here is the series who have worked
really really hard on you know making it
as comprehensive as possible we're gonna
get started with setting up burp suite
so for those of you don't know what burp
suite is burp suite is essentially an
integrated platform for performing
security testing of web applications all
right so the first thing you need to
understand is that it it will allow us
to intercept the data being sent between
your browser and the web application so
it's it's a great way of understanding
how data is being transferred and how
data can be manipulative manipulated
between the client and obviously the web
application okay so the tool we're going
to be using as I said is burp suite and
I'm currently running pair to us so
don't worry if you're running Windows or
Kali Linux it doesn't really matter all
we need to do is just download and
install web suite it's pretty simple
gets the setup you don't have to
register you just download the free
community version now obviously down the
line you might choose to to buy the
professional version which I do
recommend and I have used but I don't
use it as often I'm not as you know
specifically a web penetration tester
I'm more of a I'm more of an of a web
server penetration tester so I really
work with a different vector so by
default you can choose to bite that's
once you become experienced and you know
you've chosen whether this is the path
that you want to pursue it's a fantastic
path I know a lot of people who you know
make good money with bug bounties so you
know it's something that you can look
into as well alright so let's get
started with setting up the proxy
alright so this is the intercepting
proxy that allows us to obviously to
intercept the data being sent to inform
the client and the the web the web
application so to do that we need we can
just do it through Firefox so the
browser I'll be using is Firefox you can
use whatever you want and by default you
want to go into your preferences that
can be found here preferences there we
are
and
you want to go all the way into the
bottom here that way it has the network
proxy and make sure you go into settings
and you want to go into manual proxy
configuration alright so this is we're
going to configure it to be the
localhost with the port set at 8080
alright and then you want to make sure
that this you use this server proxy for
all protocols so that is the proxy we're
going to be using and just hit OK
alright and once that's done you should
be good there
now what you want to do is just open up
burp suite so you can search for it or I
have it already on my on my little
taskbar here and I don't think I've
updated it for a while so I'll probably
need to do that later but for now I'll
just close that the update prompt and
it's going to prompt you welcome to burp
suite and it's gonna say not depending
on the version that you've chosen to
select whether they have chosen the
community version which is what I have
here or the free version as it's called
and you then have the pro version so by
default the community version only
allows you to use a temporary project if
you have the professional version that
allows you to save your project which is
you know great functionality as well so
just hit next and you just want to it
use the defaults and just hit start back
and just give that a few seconds to
start it up all right and I'll explain
the interface generally but we'll be
looking more into how burp works in the
next video I just want to get you set up
with burp in this video and you
understand what exactly is going on
alright so welcome to burp now by
default again it may seem a little bit
intimidating mostly because if you're a
beginner you have not heard of any of
these of these words here and you don't
really know what they are doing alright
so by default you have your target proxy
spider scan into the repeater sequence
ID code a comparator your project
options your user options and alerts
we'll be going through all of this as we
as we know perform real-world testing on
our on our vulnerable on our vulnerable
target I'll be showing you how to set up
a damn vulnerable web application soon
and many others but for now just focus
on burp suite alright so by default you
want to just go into proxy alright and
for some reason I already have some data
here
so you know what I'm just going to leave
that as it is I just want to turn or
intercept off so we are not intercepting
any traffic as of yet and you want to go
into your options and you want to make
sure that your proxy listeners as you
can see but proxy uses listeners to
receive incoming HTTP requests from your
browser so you have to make sure that
your proxy is set as the as the one we
set in Firefox which is the localhost
one twenty seven point zero point zero
point one and the port is 8080 and make
sure that that is running alright you
can also create your own and add it here
and you can also remove it so you get
the idea now by default if I just go
back to my intercept if I just go back
to my browser and this is where the real
magic happens if I just you know if I
just open this and I type in a simple
test site example.com and I just hit
enter all right it's gonna load it up
here but if we're going to burp suite
and I go into HTTP 3 you can see that by
default there are some are Firefox
portals you know some get methods here
but we'll be looking at all of these
methods or requests by default you can
see that the example.com
the example.com URL that we entered you
can see there is a get request and
furthermore if you go down to the bottom
here you can see there is some more
information regarding what a request was
sent to the web application or so by
default you can see that the host was
example.com and it gives you more
information like the accept language the
encoding the connection and if you look
at the headers you can see that the the
header shows you know very very clearly
you have your get host user agent accept
language they accept encoding connection
etc etc so you might be a little bit
confused if this is your first time
hearing about you know headers and the
request and response paths but don't
worry about that we'll get to all of
this for now if I just go back into
intercept and let me just open up my
browser here and we open something like
the my website which is say a chestplate
com
so before we do that I just want to hit
intercept on alright so
it's going to intercept actively and
we're just going to HS play.com and I
hit go alright know by default is going
to tell me that essentially that the my
connection is not secure don't worry
about this just go into your and just
add this as an exception there we are
I'm going to confirm exception and now
it's still not going to load the website
and the reason being is we've not for
that at the request and they are being
intercepted by burp suite alright so if
I go into back into burp suite you can
see that it has started the intercept
process and by default you can see that
we need to Ford
we need to Ford the request here so if I
just Ford it
let me just fold that again there we are
let me just for them for hack exploit
there we are that's the correct one so
I'll Ford this again and there we are so
now Hawk exploit should be up and
running and as you can see I should have
loaded the site give that a few seconds
there we are
alright so as you can see that is how
you intercept the data that is being
sent from the client to the web
application and furthermore that's how
you you can analyze the data being sent
and furthermore manipulate it to
obviously find vulnerabilities within
the web application
alright so irregardless of all of this I
know this was very very basic and it's
not really covered anything in terms of
web application penetration testing but
don't worry about that you know we start
off really really simple and we build on
that
we're gonna get started with spidering
more specifically spidering with bev
sweet and you know the purpose of this
video or this tutorial is to help you
understand the spidering process and how
to go about doing it with a burp suite
alright so there's gonna be a little bit
of Theory here but I'll be explaining a
lot of things so again this video is
really focused on understanding
spidering now before you get started
with that I just wanted to let you know
that the target or our web application
that we're going to be targeting we're
going to be attacking is the damn
vulnerable web application now if you
don't know what the damn vulnerable web
application is that's fine you can just
google it and I'll probably make a video
on how to get it installed on kali linux
but what i would recommend if you're you
know begin or even if you're a
professional in hacking probably one of
the best things that you need to have
you know in your kit is Metasploit abort
- alright and for the simple reason that
it contains first of and foremost a
vulnerable operating system and secondly
it contains all the vulnerable web
applications that will be using at one
stage during this series ok so we're
going to be starting off with the damn
vulnerable web application as I said it
comes pre-installed with Metasploit able
to so all you need to do is get the
local IP address on your Metasploit able
to virtual machine which in my case is
192 point one sixty eight point one
point one or two so what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna open up my browser and I'm
just going to open up that web that IP
address point one point one or two and
just give it a few seconds to load up as
you can see there we are
that's Metasploit able to and it's going
to prompt us to select what vulnerable
web app we want to use in this case
we're going to select the dvwa which is
the damn vulnerable web application so
just click on that and now it's gonna
ask you for your admin and password in
this case for your username and password
sorry about that in this case the
username is admin and the password is
password alright so just hit login and
it's going to log you into the damned
vulnerable web application now we'll be
looking at this either more in a later
video and the reason is we have to go
through all of these options but for now
if you go to the if I can just remember
where it was if I can just go to the
security so to the damn vulnerable web
applications
security at the moment it was high
because I was actually performing some
tests on it but just change it to medium
or low but for now you won't be using it
I was just letting you know what web
application we're going to be using all
right that being said let's move on to
burp suite all right and we can I can
start explaining the spidering process
all right so let me just open up web
suite so I've updated it to the latest
version I think I'm running Catalan X
now in the previous video I was running
parrot so I think they should be an
update but I could be wrong so let's
just give that a few seconds to start up
yeah there is an update so I'll do that
later and we'll just click on create our
temporary project and use the web
default and start that okay so once that
starting let me explain what spidering
is right now the purpose of spidering is
to identify our scope all right or what
what we want to scan now this is not
exactly scanning and we'll be looking at
scanning but essentially a spidering is
the process of mapping out our web
application and it's very very useful
for finding links and and web forms
which is also very important because it
will allow us to then furthermore attack
the web forms manipulate headers etc etc
all right now when you talk about
automatic spider ring with web suite
it's essentially when when burp is
spidering it follows links and I it'll
it'll start following links and we'll
start identifying for files folders and
forms from the web application and it'll
the the great thing about this is it
will record all the requests and
responses while it's performing the
dhole spidering process okay so once you
have a burp suite opened up here you can
let me just expand it so we have a
greater picture of what's going on
exactly
sorry if my virtual machine is a little
bit slow I need to configure it
correctly anyway what you want to do is
we have looked at the proxy check
section let's look at the spider section
and in here this is a very very simple
menu and to understand it you can see
that we have two tabs available we have
the control tab and we have the options
tab alright the control tab essentially
if we just click if I just look if we
look at it as you can see these settings
are used to monitor and control the
depth spider so it allows you to stop to
stock and stir
the web spidering and you can also clear
the queues all right when you look at
the options which is right here sorry
about that when you look at the options
there are a lot of options we'll be
looking at them and we'll be looking at
them in a second sorry about that
I actually got an email apologies there
let's get started now with the control
section so the control section if the
log we are able to control this by the
status where we can stop it and start it
and you know furthermore we can clear
the queues that already exist there all
right we then have despite the scope
where we can we can define our own scope
and depending on what we want to spider
we'll look at that in a few seconds and
finally if we look at the well if we
look in the options section here we have
the crawler settings which allow us to
specify the way the spider is going to
crawl for the web content on the web
application we'll be looking at the
maximum link depth and what that means
passive spidering
that allows us to essentially spider to
continue spidering when we are looking
through or we're going through the web
application we're performing requests
and responses when they're performing
requests as for the form submission this
is probably something that we'll be
looking at in the next video and we'll
be doing this practically we will be
actually performing the we'll be
performing this by drilling process but
for now let me see what else yes the
request headers the request headers are
used to you can manipulate essentially
the headers if you've learned about HTTP
headers by the way I really want to
cover HTTP because it's very important
that you understand how the headers work
but we'll be looking at this all in
advance but now let's start off with the
spider status not really the spider
status but looking at the control tab if
you look at the spider scope you can see
that you can it'll use the default suite
scope which is defined in the target tab
if you just click on use a custom scope
you can see that okay first you if you
just click on this little cog here you
can restore the defaults you can load
your own and you can save the options so
that's just to do with that now and you
talked about using the advanced scope
here's where you can essentially
this is where you specify what you want
to map so you can specify a host deport
etc etc okay again we'll be looking at
all of this as we move along but for now
we're just going to use the default
suite scope we can just if once you
click on that is going to stop that the
spidering process but we don't need it
right now so I'm just gonna come just
gonna pause it and if we move on to the
options now the options tab has a lot of
stuff that we need to look into first
and foremost we have the CRO the crawler
settings alright so when we're talking
about the basic options so for example
we can specify what the spider will
crawl for so it you can choose to select
for robot the robots.txt file which is
very important because it shows you you
know exclusions you then can detect you
can ignore the links to non-text content
you can request the root of all
directories very important stuff but
again you can customize this to your
liking now one of the things I would
recommend that you do not touch with if
you do not know what you're doing yet is
the maximum link depth rate the maximum
link that is essentially the number of
links you want the spider to to
essentially to crawl or to to map now by
default five is in my in my in my
situation or in my case what I like
doing is alternating between three to
five anything higher than that will
usually overload the web application and
it will cause it to lag or to respond
very very slowly and you know again that
might not mean a lot right now but trust
me when you'll actually be performing
the penetration test on the web
application you really need a good
response otherwise you have your time to
live that cetera et cetera okay so let's
look at what passes spidering is all
right so specia spidering and set is
essentially just it allows you to
continue scanning you know or going
through or actually performing your
requests how as as it it essentially
allows you to us continue the spidering
process as you're performing any other
task so as you can see passing spidering
monitors monitors traffic through the
proxy to update the sitemap without
making any new requests right so
passively spied as you browse you can
also select
link that's associated with proxy
requests now this out recommend keeping
it at zero to two and that's because
again you do not want a very very deep
link depth in the sense that you're also
going to be performing your own requests
and you'll be doing many other things
you could be looking at the decoder or
you could be looking at you could be
focusing on the target and you don't
want it again to to slow down the web
application alright so form submission
again this is something that I said
we'll be talking about in the in the
next video because it is quite advanced
and we'll get started with the damn
vulnerable web application there moving
on to the spider engine we'll be looking
at application login as well but for now
just we will just skip over that when we
talk about despite the engine alright
these settings are controlled the engine
use for making HTTP requests one
spidering all right so this allows you
to change the number of threads you want
to use and as I said using more than you
can see right now it's at ten what our
recommend is still keeping it between
the range of two to five oh you might
you might cause the web application to
slow down and these are more advanced
settings that you can use it dependent
on timing all right and we've talked
about the request headers they allow you
to modify the way the spider will will
look towards the web applications for
example you could you could edit the the
device that is being used and you could
change it for example into a mobile
device and you get the idea you are let
you essentially allows you to to change
the request headers and from that
obviously you would get a response back
dependent on what you changed alright so
that was the spider ring or actually the
theory revolving on spidering now we'll
be looking at how spidering really works
in the next video I know some of you may
not like this that I actually went
through your theory and I haven't talked
about doing anything but remember it's
very very important to understand what
exactly is happening behind spider ring
and in the next video we'll actually get
started with the spidering process
gotta get started with brute-forcing
with all right so our vulnerable web
application of choice is going to be the
damn vulnerable web application as we
discussed in the previous video all
right and I'm gonna be using Metasploit
able to as well as my server by default
you can install Metis file you can
install the damn vulnerable web
application on your Kali Linux and you
can host it on your local on your local
server and you can you can then perform
your attacks but I like running it from
an another virtual machine and as you
can see I'm running it on the Metasploit
able to virtual machine and by default
it's connected to my local network and
it's bridged so you can see that my
local IP address is 192.168.1.1 or two
all right so I already have the damn
vulnerable web application open as you
can see it is running on to that IP
address of the Metasploit able to
virtual machine under the damn
vulnerable web application so for those
of you asking why I'm using Metasploit
able to instead of Metasploit able
treats because Metasploit able to has a
a much larger choice in terms of
vulnerable web applications and it's
really good for practicing all right so
make sure you're logged into your damn
vulnerable web application you need the
default username is admin and the
password is password all right is really
very simple all right by default in this
video we're gonna set our security level
to low if you don't know how to do that
you can go into your damn venerable web
application security and you can set
that to low and you can just hit submit
the reason we're setting it to low is
because most logins are you know if you
look at the real world if you're talking
about big sites this attack may very
well work on sites that are older or
sites that have not been updated or
sites that don't have good security
you'll be shocked to find some really
big companies that actually don't have
any login protection or brute force
protection for that matter now that
being said what I was talking about is
if we great the brute force
you can see that we have a login prompt
here now I've forgotten the username and
password and we're going to be
brute-forcing it alive all right but
before we do that we need to actually
start our bug alright so start up web
suite and you can see I'm using the
community edition and it is the latest
version alright so make sure that yours
is the latest version obviously for
obvious reasons and we're just gonna
start a temporary project because I
don't use the pro version and we're
gonna hit use the perb defaults when a
startup
alright give
that a few seconds to stop the to start
burp and now you want to make sure you
you're using the proxy so we're going to
go into preferences and advanced and
whoops burp is opened up limit is going
to my proxies network settings and we
make sure that it's using the manual
proxy configuration which is the
localhost one twenty seven point zero
point zero point one and the port is
8080 work on it ok excellent
now we need to move into burp back again
and we want to make sure that we go into
proxy and the intercept is set to OFF
alright the reason we're setting the
intercept off is because I just want to
show you something first
now by default intercept essentially
just means that you're not intercepting
the request the requests and the
responses being sent from the web
application to your browser ok so we
have already set the proxy for the
browser but we're not intercepting so if
we just test a random username like test
and we say a password like 1 2 3 4 5 you
can see if I hit login it's gonna tell
me that that is incorrect now if I set
the intercept to on to see the request
let me just turn it on and we can now
reload this so we can say test and the
password 1 2 3 4 5 we can see that now
it's for some reason let me just for
that I'll have to actually just turn
that off and we now say login and for
some reason that is not allowing us
because we have to reload all right so
now if I hit intercept on and oops let
me just open up my browser and they hit
the post 1 3 4 5 login for some reason
it's gonna you know it's gonna reload in
here I probably there we are all right
so I've reloaded the page and as you can
see now the intercept is on and we go
back to burp you can see that we got the
get request being sent by the web
application
now let's inspect it for a while now
we'll be looking at what all of this
really means but by by default the most
important thing right now is the get
request all right so you can see that
the get request has two values here it
has the username and the and the
password now that the values are again
are not important we are going to be
brute-forcing the values but it's very
important to get the fields that we are
using here now what am I talking about
if you look at the cookie you can see
the security is low and if you are to
edit the
value and for the package you can set it
too high that is basic stuff that's kid
stuff right but now we want to brute
force this login all right and how do we
do that you can see the first thing we
need to do is we're going to be using
the intruder alright so if you're a bit
confused about what the in today is
don't be worried the intruder is
essentially a Lola allows us to edit the
parameters it allows us to edit the
requests and then obviously edit them
and manipulate them so he can get the
desired results now the great thing
about the in the intruder is it allows
us to perform attacks like the brute
force etc etc alright but now what we
need to do is we need to send this
request into the intruder so that we can
send our own response alright so we're
going to right click and send to
intruder so we just send it to intruder
and once it's sent to the intruder you
can just hit forward alright we don't
need to India we don't need that get
requests anymore so now you want to go
into it the intruder and you want to go
into your positions and as you can see
in your positions you have got you have
got the get request that we were we are
just intercepted and now you can see
something really interesting it's
highlighted for you all the different
payloads okay or the different fields
that we can brute force for by default
we have the username value the password
value the login value we have the eff at
the SF ID value we have the the cookie
value no no no we don't need all of this
the only values that we need are the
user name and the password value so the
most important thing you need to do
right now is you need to clear just hit
clear all right oops sorry not that
clear I beg I know I beg your apology
there I sorry I didn't mean that autumn
rain you say is I'm sorry just clear
just hit clear and as you can see now no
values are being selected to be brute
force against so now we need to select
them manually but before that we're
going to be using the the cluster bomb
attack type alright the reason we're
using the cluster bomb attack type is
because we are going to be using two
values we are brute-forcing against two
values remember that okay and these need
to be set in in combination so that
means it's much better to use a cluster
bomb because essentially your clustering
two values that need to be there need to
be tested against the login the law
in application or the login form
together alright so in a combination so
we need to select cluster bomb and now
we need to select the values because
those are the those are that is what we
want to brute force again so just
highlight this value it doesn't matter
the password or the username is just
highlight it and you won't do it at all
right so just hit add and as you can see
we have selected that you know I'm going
to the password and you want to
highlight that as well
and you just want to add that as you can
see now once you have added that those
are the two values were going to be
brute-forcing against make sure that
none of the others are selected none of
the other values once that is done yo
you're almost there now now you want to
go into your payloads right now in your
payloads you want to make sure that your
payload set is set to 2 which is you're
using him and your password so let's
start off with your payload set as
payload 1 alright as your payload type
make sure that that is a simple list
because you can see we're only targeting
user names and passwords so we don't
need you know run tanked file or we are
not changing anything
you know dependent on Unicode etc you
get the idea ok so simple list and now
you quaint your payload options which is
where you select your user list or your
password list or your word list now we
are not using a word list but if you
want to you can if you're performing
this on a real site which I don't
recommend unless you have written
permission now since we're using this in
our penetration testing lab we are going
to just add the default user names and
said the security of the site is low and
it's not really a complex a brute force
to crack ok so what we want to do is
wait we want to make sure we have set
payload set to 1
which is going to be for our user names
so now we can go into load where you can
load your different user names and your
passwords or your word lists but by
default we're going to add our own all
right so we're going to say oops some
we're just gonna say we're gonna type in
and now like the commonly used user
names alright so something like admin
administrator oops for some reason I
actually let me just remove these blank
values their admin now administrator
administrator let me just type that back
in administrator like so administrator
for those of you telling me that my tie
things but that's because
my microphone is right in front of me
and I can't really see what I'm typing
administrator let's see what else what
are the default ones like we have root
we have password actually we are not
setting the passwords right now so we
can just type in the default ones like
this all right so we can say test you
know the default ones user one whatever
you think would be the most commonly
used ones okay or if you know the user
name is that is even better so we're
going to add all the user names
alright so we've added the user names
that we want to use now by default again
I'm saying you can use a word list if
you want to just going to load and
select the word list now we want to
select our passwords all right so we can
go into the payload set too and as you
can see now we can add our own values
now we can use the default word list
that come with Kali Linux so if I go
into my root and they're going to user
share and we select word lists let me
just find where word lists are if I can
find them there we are word list and the
ones that work great for me are in the
Metasploit folder and you can look for
the default passwords as you can see you
have your database default passwords you
have your default user passwords for
services that's also great it has a
great list of default usernames and
passwords that you can use but for me
I'm not going to use this because we are
sticking to the basics not now you want
to add your own password so we can
select again some randomly you know
commonly used passwords so puss you can
say password let's see what else admin
you know admin again whoops let me just
remove that one admin root you can use
root let's see let me think one two
three four five that also one that I've
seen many network administrators using
one two three four five and you you get
the idea alright so we've set our two
payloads payload one is set for
usernames below two is set for passwords
excellent alright now we have selected
all payload types we've selected we have
added our payload options we don't need
to look at payload processing that is
advanced
once that's done what you want to do is
going to intruder and start the attack
alright and now it's going to tell you
that the community edition of burp
contains a demo version but it's it's
essentially telling you that the process
is going to be slow alright so we're
gonna hit OK
and it's going to start at the attack as
you can see it's going through all the
combinations and as you can see there
are combinations that we have here are
25 and it's going to go through all of
them now one great thing that you need
to do here or one important thing that
you need to do is you need to understand
the status codes that the server or the
web application is sending back now
that's a good way of in understanding
what password is correct and what what
user name is correct and what password
is not correct okay so if we look now at
the at the results as you can see that
it's finished it's going through the
brute force attack we check the status
the status is still the same we have a
status 200 if we look at the length all
right the length is going to be still
the same but you have to look for things
that are not that are not matching so
for example you can see that the length
here that was returned was 49 48 and
it's not it's not following the format
of the others so that means that this
could be the username and password don't
worry about the status the status will
still remain the same regardless of that
but when we'll be looking at advanced
server penetration testing that's
something important so you can see that
they get that we've got here is very
important now if we look at the if we
look at the response that will be sent
right there you can see the the response
and if we render it you can see that if
it was successful it will tell us that
we've logged in successfully
so let me just browse down all the way
as you can see welcome to the password
protected area admin and there you go
that is the username and the password
it is admin and password now again this
was really simple again you can you can
increase the security if you are
practicing on your own but you can see
that this really works and this is how
to utilize Bob for advanced stuff like
brute forcing now again most of the
advanced websites nowadays have great
content management systems that have the
security plugins that essentially
prevent you from brute forcing or lock
you out but most of the older sites
you'll be you'll be actually quite
shocked to find out that their brute
forces did their login form sorry are
not protected now we have already logged
in and we can see that the default
username is admin and the password is
password okay so you can look at the row
the Royal ctp here you can
the request and the response you can
look at them and you can inspect them if
that's what you do and you can look at
the headers what's being sent all that
good stuff but that was going to be it
for this video and now if we just go
back into burp let me just go into my
proxy and I'm going to disable intercept
and we can try and log in here so we
know that the admin the username is
admin and the password is password so
let me login and welcome to the password
protected admin area fantastic
in this video we're going to be looking
at selecting our burbs with our target
InBev sweet adding it to our scope and
then finally spidering it as my
vulnerable operating system I'm going to
be using the Mattila day which comes
pre-installed on Metasploit able to so
you should download well I would
recommend that you download Metasploit
able to it's a fantastic option for any
of you who are just getting into
penetration testing it offers multiple
vulnerable web applications and
vulnerable systems that you can practice
with so again it's something that I
really really recommend that being said
as you can see I have met the Metasploit
able to virtual machine running and I
have already looked at my local IP
address you can do that by typing in
ifconfig that will display to you your
your current and network interface and
your local IP address because we are
doing this in our virtual penetration
testing lab alright so let's go back to
Kali Linux now and I'm gonna open up my
browser make sure you get your IP
address and as I said again we're going
to be using Mozilla day so if you don't
know what Mattila day is Mattila days
simply a vulnerable web application and
the reason i'm switching off i'm
switching from the damn venerable web
application is because i want to show
you a few i really want to make it a bit
diverse in terms of the web applications
that we use all right so let's get
started now now I already have the IP
address of my virtual machine opened up
here in my browser as you can see one
ninety two point one sixty eight point
one point 104 so if I reload this you
can see that it indeed is the Metasploit
able to server and I can just go ahead
and click on motility alright now what I
should do now is going to my preferences
you can do that by opening a new tab so
let me just open a new tab here going
into preferences and then selecting
advanced and network and finally
settings and then you want to make sure
you select a manual proxy configuration
and then make sure it's using the
localhost proxy which is one twenty
seven point zero point zero point one a
port 8080 and hit OK once that's done we
know that web suite can intercept not
that we want to do that in this video we
just want to we want to have a look
at we want to map the web application
all right so we're not going to change
anything in motility but I'm gonna be
showing you some pretty interesting
things in this video so now we should
start up sweet community now I'm gonna
be explaining something at the end of
the video that is really important and
it is in regards to the community
version and the professional version of
web sweet and what what the differences
are and why you will need at some point
to get the professional version ok so
I'm gonna select a temporary project I'm
using the community version as of right
now hit next use the defaults and I'm
gonna start bub all right so it's gonna
start burp suite and then let me just
minimize the browser here so give that a
few seconds to start up and once it
starts up what you want to do
immediately is turn off the proxy we
want to stop the intercepting because we
are not intercepting any requests or we
are not inserting any responses so go
back into your target and now we can get
started with with actually reloading the
page right here so let's reload that and
we should be able to see what's going on
and we should have the sitemap alright
so let me just open up the web suite
here fantastic
all right so now you can see something
very interesting as happened here in our
target and sitemap we have the files
that were discovered here well
essentially we have the web server that
then has the motility folder which is
our target now before I get into any of
that the sitemap will show you the
current site map of easly a sitemap is
essentially sorry about that the site
sitemap is essentially the structure or
the format of the web page and how the
web page was constructed and how it will
function in regards to every other piece
of content okay so the first thing that
we need to do or we'll be looking at is
actually selecting your target which in
this case again is Matilda day and you
can do that by right clicking and
hitting add to scope all right so you
might be asking what exactly the scope
means well a scope essentially allows us
to define our automated spidering and
what this means is we are focusing our
only on our target we're not going to
focus on the reference links like you
can see here for example we have two it
as a reference
BACtrack dynamic drive eclipses etc etc
you get the idea so scoping is
essentially selecting our target
isolating it so that we only see what we
need to see and there obviously the
results that we want to see so I'm gonna
right click on Mattila day and I'm gonna
hit add to scope alright so now it's
going to say you've added an item to
talk to the target scope do you want but
proxy to stop sending out scope items
out of scope items to the history of the
other bug tools yes again we want to
make sure that we are we clear out all
the junk that we don't need now you
might have noticed well that's
essentially happened but nothing has
really changed and as you can see it's
gonna tell you here logging of out of
scope proxy traffic is disabled don't
worry about that just leave it as it is
if you want to re-enable it you can go
ahead but right now you don't need to do
that okay so we've looked at how to add
our target to the scope no let's look at
spidering spidering is essentially the
the first and the most important step of
web application penetration testing all
right it is it deals with or it is in it
is in relation with footprinting and
this is why I bring the comparison from
penetration testing to obviously web
application penetration testing it is to
deal it essentially deals with crawling
through the website and then it records
all the files the links and the meta
methods that it can get and that helps
us build an idea of how the web
application is structured how it works
and then finally we can learn how we can
break through it what we need to do is
we need to spy that our target we have
added it to the scope which is great and
now we need to spider it so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna we're gonna use
spidering and this will help us identify
all the links and the parameters that we
need again as I said it's like
footprinting so what you want to do is
right-click on your target which in this
case is motility and you want to it
spider this branch all right so I'm
gonna it's PI to this branch and now
something interesting is going to start
happening as you can see it's gonna
start getting all the links all the
resources that it can and it's gonna
keep prompt you with here a submit form
okay now what you can do is just ignore
the form there'll be quite a few
essentially these are default login
forms where it's asking you to enter
credentials that you might want to enter
let's say you you're performing white
box penetration testing and you have the
details you can again log in like this
and perform internal penetration test
but we're going to assume that you do
not know your penetration you're
essentially performing a penetration
test on these security so I'm gonna
ignore all of these forms okay and as
you can see there's another one right
there
and the spidering is probably continuing
now if you want to view the status of
this spy drink you can go into spider
and as you can see you have your status
of this spy drink and once it's done
you'll see that the requests made will
stop changing and the bytes transferred
will also stop changing so we can stop
the spider now you notice something that
we were faced with those form login
prompts now you can choose to to enter
them as it prompts or as you are
prompted but the better way of doing
this is to actually you can actually do
this automatically and you can do this
by going into spider and you want to go
into options and you want to go in to
your application login all right now if
you look at the form submission it is
essentially what it's doing is it's
going to use the default form
submissions that you would find in a
database so for example you have mail
first name last name surname name
address you you get the idea so those
are default values that one would one
would be expected to find now we're
looking at the application login as you
can see it's option is set to prompt for
guidance we want to change this so to
automatically submit these credentials
now in here you can enter default
credentials or if you have an idea of
what the credentials you might expect to
find now this is where creativity and
sheer information gathering comes into
play so if you anneal the default you
know usernames and passwords you can
enter them here now what I'm going to do
is I'm going to enter a string that is
well I've used it before in performing
SQL injection and we'll talk about SQL
injection because it is very advanced if
you know SQL injection or you have a you
have an idea or experience with the
databases you might understand what this
string means all right so for my
username I'm going to change that to
admin a quotation mark and you say
or one equal one and two dashes
all right space and attach now you don't
need to worry what this means for now
please do not stress about this I will
explain it when the time is right all
right so leave the password as it is and
don't worry about that now we don't need
to change anything in terms of these
tabs we talked about these tabs in the
theory section and now we can go back
into our control and Target and finally
we can spider the application again once
more so that we can enter the we can
essentially process these strings that
we that we just entered in terms of the
user name so I'm going to right click
and spider this branch okay so it's
gonna start spidering and if we look at
the spider you can see that the the
spider ring is complete and you can
essentially clear the queues if you want
to clear to clear them like so and you
can keep on running it depending on what
you want to do okay so I'm just gonna
pause it and now we have essentially
spidered the web application and you
might be asking well hmm I've seen a few
reference sites that's not helping much
you know we don't need twitter.com or
you know sizzle J's this might give us a
basic idea of what types of sites are
linked to to the web application but in
reality you can see we have hackers or
not not very important information at
all now what if we click on the mutilate
a folder oh look at that that's really
interesting now that is very very
important what has happened here is it's
given us the structure of the web
application this is vitally important
all right now again as I'm saying you
can look at how the web site or the web
application is structured so in
documentation you can see you can go
ahead and read the documentation you can
look at the images that the web site has
these styles so you can inspect the
entire site and understand what exactly
is going on here or get an idea of what
the person who developed the web site
was thinking and then finally out of
experience or as we'll be looking at out
of knowledge you can actually understand
how to exploit the system and that's we
will be talking about discovering hidden
files hidden files like admin pages
login pages you know that really juicy
stuff and we'll be talking about that in
the next video and that's because the
suite Community Edition does not
or have allow you to use that feature so
what I'm gonna do in the next video I'm
gonna be using web suite pro and also
show you an old alternative program I'm
sure you've heard of it that also works
from Windows of course above so it works
on Windows but I'm not really a Windows
fan when it comes down to penetration
testing so that being said we have
essentially spidered the application we
have the structure of the web
application and now we need to look at
something also very interesting as we
have already talked about it let me just
complete let me just show you how to get
rid of all of these reference links and
to essentially show the items in the
scope only so what you can do is just
click on filter right here this little
bar here is the filter bar so click on
it and it's gonna bring up this small
little window and you want to focus on
the filter by request type and make sure
you check show only in scope items this
will essentially filter all the results
to show you only links or resources or
files that are within the scope so once
that's done just click back on the
filter and as you can see it has got rid
of all the junk that you do not need
whatsoever and now you can essentially
look at the the requests and the
responses and analyze them accurately
defined to your scope and this will
essentially it will stop confusing you
I've seen many beginners make this
mistake where they don't define their
scope they do not know what their target
is and they're getting links that are do
not even relate to the website that
they're they're trying to perform the
penetration test on now since you know
this knowledge this will help you get a
solid foundation and again you can start
logging out of skip out of scope proxy
traffic when you want again that's very
nice that they add that button right
over there all right so now you only
have the files that you require or the
files that you're currently performing
the penetration test only now I know
this this video was slightly either
there was not a lot of action but again
it is very important that you get this
in the next video we'll be looking at
how to pull out to discover hidden files
or files in general that you are not
supposed to find okay and that can be
done by right-clicking and going into
engagement tools as you can see it is
defined to the professional version of
web suite and we will
going to discover content where I'll be
explaining to you how to find things
like the login page or the configuration
page some things that web developers you
know actually just may try to hide them
but if if actually found can really
exploit the website or can lead to the
exploitation of the website
we're gonna stop looking at how to
discover hidden files but before that I
just want to take you through a few
things all right so let's start off with
what Oh a space or OWA SP all right so
what does that mean well essentially
what it means or what it stands for is
the open web application security
project all right and it's goal well
essentially it is a nonprofit
organization whose goal is focused on
improving the security of software all
right so it's job is to improve the
security of software now this project
the OWS P or the open web application
security project created a tool called
as the Z attack proxy or as you know it
these app many people are calling it zap
and I'm sure most of you have heard of
it and you might have been you might be
leaning towards bub sweet a little bit
more but I can guarantee you that zap is
one of my favorite tools and I use it
because firstly it's free and for the
people like for the students I teach I
usually tell them to start with zap
because if you get zapped you'll
automatically get web sweet and you only
need Bob sweet when you're moving into
an enterprise environment where you know
bub so it is the recommended tool and it
is the tool that you must use to adhere
to
to certain rules and ethics that being
said zap is a fantastic tool it's
absolutely free as you can see the OWS
pz attack proxy which is you know
abbreviated as Zack is one of the
world's most popular free security tools
and is actively maintained by hundreds
of international volunteers all right so
it helps you find security
vulnerabilities in your web applications
while you're developing and testing
applications so again if you're a web
application developer this is also a
fantastic tool for you and as I said
it's going to be a fantastic alternative
to - burp suite all right now that's not
to say that burp is bad burp is more of
a Enterprise enterprise develop software
as I've mentioned in different in the
first video of this series
burp is focused on professionals now
that's not to say that zap isn't but
you'll get the idea all right so I'm
gonna be making a separate video on
installing zap and I'm going to make a
video on how to get accustomed to the
interface because it is slightly
different and the language or English
used for the interfaces again very well
I'll not say very different but it is
quite different so again getting used to
it was also something that is quite
helpful because we'll be needing some of
the enterprise features and only a tool
like SAP will be a great alternative
however if you do have burp suite pro go
ahead it'll it'll just be the same thing
as I mentioned in the previous video
it's really very easy to to follow up
where we left ok
that being said it runs on the same
network proxy it runs on the local host
so make sure you're running it on the
local host and on port 8080 I'll be
showing you how to change the port if
you so feel you want to that's also
another great thing about as a SAP is it
allows you to change the proxies so I
have more Tilly they opened up here and
it is again running on my Metasploit
able to virtual machine and it's running
on the IP address my local IP address
192.168.1.1 o4 as you can see more till
the day all right so that's working
perfectly
so let me just leave those other tabs
open because again there's no there's no
real harm ok so again you can configure
the material a security level if that's
what you want you know to to make things
harder but I'm just gonna be showing you
the focus of this video which is how to
find hidden files now you might be
asking why do we need to find hidden
files or why do we need to discover
these hidden files well hidden files
firstly are the files like admin login
pages you know maybe a robots.txt but
that's not really something that's
hidden nowadays it could be a text e
containing maybe usernames you know
something really weird or I you know
pardon my English or pardon my language
something dumb that the web developers
left behind or you know just not
configured correctly and you'll see what
I mean in a few seconds alright so again
these are the files that are hidden and
you will not find them after spidering
your web application or website alright
so let's get started with zap as you can
see at the logo right here on my it's
added to my favorites let me just launch
it give it a few seconds and it should
start up there we are these up give it a
few seconds again and make sure you
update it usually the updates for the
modules vary
regularly so make sure you update them
to the latest version as they improve
the speed and a so on and so forth all
right so it's gonna prompt you here do
you want to persist the SAP session that
means do you want to save this SAP
session I don't I do not want to persist
at the session at this moment in time so
I'm great
start again don't worry if you're not
familiar with the interface I'll be
going through it in another video
because it deserves now you might be a
little bit overwhelmed but do not worry
do not stop going to you know URLs to
attack that may seem really really
tempting but again you know let's take
it nice and easy
so let's talk about the proxy how to
change the proxies so to do that you can
go into your [ __ ] right here as you can
see or you can go into tools and go into
options all right but I like going into
this little cog here and once you press
on once you click on the COG let me just
enlarge that you will see that you have
this huge menu and again as I said Zapp
is a really advanced tool and in some
cases can totally replace burp suite now
looking at the proxies you want to go
for the local proxies right here it's
obviously starting with L so local
proxies and make sure that the address
is hosted on localhost and you can
change the port if you're using burp
suite and stuff like you're just if
you're using both the applications at
the same time or you're running
something on localhost already so you
can change it to something like 80 81
whatever you feel is comfortable for you
ok
so that's how to change your proxies and
if you're running behind a NAT you can
also check this and you should be good
there if you don't find that the proxy
is working suggest it ok all right now
you see that there's not we are not
going to be looking at intercepting
right now but we will be looking at that
in a few in probably the next videos the
advanced videos with SAP alright so let
me just reload the material date page
and as you can see I'm running the proxy
so I'm just going to reload the page and
as you can see we are not intercepting
actively so whoa what's this well we got
some files here let me just reload the
page one more time and there we are we
are getting some results so we get the
IP 192.168.1.1 o4 that's the server and
we just click on this drop down here we
get the get request so you can analyze
the get request if that's what you want
so you can right click and then analyze
all right no will will not be looking at
that right now because I won't focus on
finding the or discovering the hidden
files so what we'll do is we want to
click on the motility folder now one of
the great things I like about sap is it
already gives you the file structure or
the website structure immediately here
alright so you can see you have your
images folder which has its the images
there your JavaScript styles and all the
resources are in regards to the website
that it could find
naturally all right so if we if we just
look at the bottom here you can see that
it it's showing you a timestamp with the
method that the URL and it gives you the
the code which means the pages in this
case the 200 code means the page was
found you have the reason you have the
rtt Desai's the alert as you can see
it's telling us we have a high alert
here now don't worry about that again
these are things that you know will be
will really be tempting but again let's
take it slow all right so the first
thing you want to do or you need to do
is to right-click here and you want to
go to attack and hit spider
all right so we want to spider the
website of the web application and start
scan' do not touch anything here just
make sure it's using the appropriate
server address and just hit scan all
right now it's great to spider the
entire web application it's going to
give you a little progress bar here you
can pause it or stop it which is also
great to see at the bottom you should
have also noticed that you have your
tabs here that work really really well
and as you can see the the website now
is completely spidered and if we just
check all the files that we can't find
now you can see that we have some more
JavaScript files and essentially what's
happened here is the entire site has
been has been spotted ok now we already
did this with bub and the you know you
probably really bored of this right now
so what we're gonna do now is we need to
we need to start discovering the hidden
content right so let me just close all
of this up there we are fantastic now
let me just open that up and let's go to
Mattila day
oops my bad sorry about that guys and we
want to right-click on Mozilla day and
you want to go to attack and you want to
go to forced browse directory and
children that's very important for
browser directory will not display
everything we'll also be looking at
fussing but that's for later all right
so you want to make sure you hit force
browser directory just click on that and
it's going to open the up this tab here
so you can see we had despite the tab
open which you can close if you're not
using it which is also great
I really like the management of SAP you
then have output for four outputs alerts
as you can see you have some alerts here
that I will alert you on some potential
vulnerabilities so for example
application error disclose you have some
cookies no HTTP flags so again awesome
stuff there we have the get request all
that good stuff which is again focused
on a different type of attack and as you
can see by default we've got the
robots.txt here which you can analyze if
you want to buy rare clicking and going
ahead and doing that so you can copy the
URL to the browser so again copy the URL
to clipboard
alright and if we just try and explore
this let me just paste them to go here
as you can see well for some reason we
are not actually getting robots to txt
let me use the motility
motility or actually you know what let's
not do that right now because I really
want to stay on topic here so I'm just
gonna go back into that again I always
love going off to put forth topic for
some reason ok so make sure you click on
motility and you want to right-click on
it and now oh sorry we already did the
forced browser right click go to attack
and forced browse directory and children
all right now it's going to open up this
tab here and it's gonna it's gonna make
you choose this site as you can see you
have your site IP here now you need to
select the default directory list - it's
going to use this list here this default
list that comes already with zap and now
it's going to try and use it in a sort
of a brute force way to try and detect
the hidden files and folders and once it
gets the results it's going to enumerate
them ok so now you want to right click
again on it after you've selected the
list
and hit attack and you want to go to
footballs directory and children and
once you hit that it's gonna start the
process now again this is going to take
a long as well not a long time depending
on this the the size of the website if
the site is huge then again it's gonna
take a while and as you can see
immediately we're getting some submitted
files so let's let's wait for this code
to complete and I know motility has some
very very interesting files here that
I'm sure we'll be happy to get alright
so just a let let it go through this as
you can see you can check the progress
as you're going here and again that the
if you look at the status code you can
see 200 means the pages were found so
you can just go ahead and look for
things that are irregular and I'm sure
we can find something here that we
haven't found before or you can look at
the at the file form the website
directory here
so um motility let's see if we can find
something that is really really
interesting here so we have the includes
you have the get indexed of PHP they get
requests sorry for the index dot oh we
have something interesting here we have
a notes folder AHA now we're talking now
this is where stuff gets really exciting
alright so we have our ups where'd it go
there we are so in in notes we have some
very interesting files in notes so we
have a get passwords
now what happens what's this about
alright so what if what what if we just
open this URL in the browser
alright so let me just try and open that
in Firefox I just want to see what it's
gonna be all about so hopefully it's
opened up in my browser if it's not I'll
have to copy the URL probably because I
haven't set any any default all right so
copy or else to clipboard and let me
just paste that in there please don't go
there we are motility and passwords all
right so you can see that this folder or
this file was hidden and we have
interesting txt file here which again is
quite scary to go we did open Firefox
well don't doesn't look like we need
that instance so getting back to the
topic here for some reason process
unexpectedly closed with alright so that
looks like we have a Java error there
so let me just go back in over here so
again we found an accounts dot txt file
what could that be carrying let's click
on that oh boy
so again we have accounts here and well
I'm pretty sure you would know what this
means this is just bad practice from the
website developer where he wrote notes
and essentially these are the accounts
now let's see what else we can find
let's see accounts nothing interesting
in accounts because we now have the
account so that makes our brute force
much easier you then have let's see if
we can find any passwords if they were
ever saved here I'm pretty sure they are
not but we can look for some interesting
files here that can be really
interesting you can look at the site map
if you want to so let's also copy that
let's see if it gives us access to the
site map also very very important stuff
there oh yeah so the site map for some
reason we were not able to process it
all right let's look for some other
files here let me just open that utility
again so we have the get images let's
see if we run the get images let's see
what images we can get again I'm going
pretty amateurish on this I'm just
clicking on everything but I'm just
trying to show you the amount of files
that you can find as you can see
immediately you can find that the
refresh button you know all the icons
related to the website you have the i
hack banner oh yeah hackers for charity
man so I'm talking about YouTube oh my
god what an old logo that is yet the OWS
P logo pretty cool pretty cool and yeah
so you get the idea so this is how you
actually go through website and find
files that could contain you know stuff
that is quite interesting to be honest
so let's see what else we can find I'm
just gonna go to one more resource here
that we've found oh we have to get
register Wow
now that's what I'm talking about copy
URL to clipboard that's actually this is
actually quite fun this why bug bounty
hunting is oh yeah now this what I'm
told we can actually register our we can
actually register ourselves on the
website now again looking at the website
from here
doesn't look like we can can we even
register on this website I'm not sure it
can for some reason it's not actually
letting me scroll to the top but hi I
don't really know what's going on there
so let's see if we can definitely log in
render and register sorry about that we
can register there so yes it is the
register it does exist so that wasn't
actually hidden but it was hidden it was
hidden to the woman when we spied at the
website so that means indeed it was
hidden for obvious reasons because the
brute force for example if you find the
login which is again here and again if
this is hidden you can imagine the
damage that you can do so again you can
login from there set up database now
that's interesting for some reasons not
letting me copy alright so looks like we
got set up database here so here we can
okay I do not want to manually edit the
request no I do not want to manually
edit the request for some reason my
keyboard is being pressed here wow
that's weird man copy or else to
clipboard alright sorry about that my
spacebar was being mashed on by my
tablet in front of me right so let me
just there we are so no PHP MySQL errors
were resetting so I simply reset the
database and you can see the damage that
this can do so again that is some good
stuff that you can have fun with when
especially with motility you can
increase the security and find what
other files you can you can find you
know with Zapp again Zapp is a fantastic
alternative that you can use if you know
if you're not ready to invest in web
sweetie that's totally fine I used as
app for I think about three years
especially since 2014 I think I used it
until about I think twenty sixteen or
seventeen I'm not too strong and it
worked great for me I really enjoyed it
and I'm just getting back to I'm just
remembering how all the tool used to
work it was actually quite a user
intuitive interface because I just
remember right-clicking means you can
copy the URL you can inspect it you can
change the request you can attack all
that good stuff and you know it's sorted
out really well
alright then you can look at the
requests here you can change them to
whatever you want and then send them you
can intercept them it essentially does
whatever Bob sweet does
we're going to be looking at
application firewalls or WAAFs as
they're called now this may be a new
term for you and do not worry this is
now when we move into a more
professional level and again this is
what I've been talking about is most
people out there or most documented
documentation out there won't cover the
most important industry standards you
know now when I'm talking about web
application firewalls what I mean is is
these are the protection or these are
the mitigation procedures put in place
to protect a web application from
attacks obviously now as a penetration
tester or if you're looking at it from a
white hat or a black hat perspective
from white hat perspective it's always
important to have a Web Application
Firewall and I'll probably make another
video showing you how to set it up it's
really easy and it's free and it'll
probably remove about 20% of attacks ok
so that's if you're a white hat now if
you're a black hat and you're targeting
or you're performing a penetration test
legally on a web site or web application
usually what the employer will tell you
is they'll give you a scope of the
project and again they might give you
the source code etc etc you get the idea
you have your white box testing black
box and gray box but coming back to the
firewall most of them wouldn't know that
there is a file and that's because the
person who set the website up for them
in terms of hosting or the web
application for them will in most cases
on a professional level have a Web
Application Firewall now you might be a
bit confused and you might be saying
well why is this important when
performing a penetration test well this
is important because firstly it's
something that most pen testers overlook
and if you know this you've got an ace
up your sleeve
all right so essentially what's
happening is if it's being used if a web
application firewall is being used you
obviously first need to detect it and
I'm going to show you how to detect it
in this video using a special tool that
I don't think you've ever heard of but
it's also industry standard so this is a
really secret I don't know for some
reason it's not just it's something that
just hasn't caught up yet but hopefully
after this video you know about it
all right so essentially the purpose of
a web application firewall is it
protects the web application
you know from a firewall point of view
in the sense that it blocks attacks as a
one would expect them to come now what
does this mean for you well this means
that you will need to in you will need
to manipulate any type of data that is
going to be encoded all right so what
this means is if you're if you're
performing a penetration test that
involves you manipulating data and
sending it back to the web application
then you need to encode it in a specific
way to bypass the firewall otherwise it
will be blocked by the firewall and I'm
sure most of you have actually done this
before if you're just a mature
penetration testers and you've just
begun you'll find that for some reason
your requests aren't being processed and
that's because they've there is a
firewall set up to prevent these
malicious requests from being processed
okay so again Web Application Firewall
is really really important now looking
at the tool we'll be using the tool has
actually a very very funny name if for
some of you might find it hilarious it
is called wife wolf now for those of you
have heard of it
you pretty much already know how to
detect a web application firewall but
it's really very very simple all right
so just open up your terminal and what
you want to do is you want to type in
wife wolf all right so this is how it is
going to be spelt so it's worth wolf
with a two with two zeros and the syntax
is pretty simple if I just hit enter
as you can see wife Wolf's a web
application firewall detection tool
all right so credits go to the author
it's actually it's a tool that's been
there since the I think almost the last
version of backtrack and the first
version of Kali so again quite an old
tool I when I say old I mean you know I
mean that with respect given the fact
that it's really really useful and I've
used it a lot because it saves you a lot
of time and what I'm talking about is so
let's say we want to scan a website okay
in this case I have my WordPress server
running here and as you can see it's the
site is being hosted on one ninety two
point nine sixty eight point one point
101 all right so I have that IP opened
up in my browser and as you can see it's
a wordpress site and this site is
vulnerable and this is what we're going
to be performing later on the
penetration test
but for now we want to find out whether
it has a firewall now by default I know
it doesn't have a firewall but let's see
what waffle foot tell us all right so
the syntax is very simple as you can see
you just type in wife woof and you enter
your URL or your URL so you can enter as
many as you like okay so it'll give you
an example there how to go about it make
sure you enter your HTTP or HTTPS
protocol and we just let's try that out
so laugh wolf and we specify our
protocol HTTP in this case and the IP
address 192.168.1.1 oh one alright now
in this case I'm pretty sure that it
won't detect any web application
firewall so let me just hit enter and as
you can see no web application firewall
detected by the generic detection all
right now this is very very advanced and
this tool is an industry standard and if
it does tell you that there is no web
application firewall then by all means I
can guarantee that it does not have a
firewall now let's look at one of my
sites that I currently own it's a site
that I use it's actually my web
development company that obviously we
use for web development now I've
protected this site with a web
application firewall provided by cloud
fair now for those of you web developers
and when you're performing your hosting
you know that using cloud fair is
awesome because it allows you to
optimize your site for speed it allows
you to purge assets and make your site
faster protect it and again protected
from DDoS attacks etc etc all the good
stuff so let's see if it will actually
detect this so I'm going to type in wife
wolf I know that name is really really
funny the protocol is HTTP HTTPS like so
and I'm going to specify the site which
is elkhorn studios.com alright el cajon
studios.com and if i enter as you can
see it's gonna start checking the site
give it a few seconds it shouldn't take
any much you know a lot of time and as
you can see the site Algren studios.com
is behind cloud fair all right now what
this means is that most of the most of
the attacks that involve manipulation of
data will be in some way blocked and you
know you won't get your response back
the way
wanted it and the render wouldn't be the
same all right now again as you can see
it's detected that it is behind a Web
Application Firewall now the next step
is how to encode these how to encode and
code iam your requests that you're going
to be sending to the web application and
that's what we'll be looking at as we
increase the security level using the
determinable web application alright so
I thought this is something that I
really need to share with you again it's
going to really help you and I promise
you this is something that you know if
you go for a job interview or you're
performing a penetration test for a
company this is something that most of
the network or systems administrators
are very keen on they want to know
whether you really know your stuff and
whether you're really up to date with
how to detect first of all because
information gathering is really
important and as you can see this tool
is fantastic and once you know this a
firewall you then have a better idea of
how to target and you won't be wasting
time again that's something that most of
the amateurs or beginners do they waste
a lot of time trying different commands
that they've seen but if they find it
under they see that it doesn't work and
they're like how's this possible am i
doing something wrong
the truth is the web application is
probably well protected so again you
know do not use this for any malicious
purposes again this is simply an
information gathering to
I'm gonna be showing you how to use the
Buster to discover directories and files
on a website or a web application you
might be asking yourself what is the
Buster or if you haven't heard of the
Buster let me explain it to you alright
so there buster is essentially a tool
that was developed by OS the open web
application security project and
essentially uses a brute forcing to find
commonly used directories and file names
on servers all right so this tool is
extremely useful for those of you who
are doing CTFs or for those of you who
are bug bounty hunters because
essentially it allows you to understand
the structure of a web web application
or a website in terms of the files and
directories and how they are structured
alright so why is this important well
this is important because this will help
us understand how we can attack a site
or what type of attack vectors we can we
can we can find you know so for example
if I had a web application and I'm going
to demonstrate that right now and I
scanned it with the bust and we found
some hidden directories and hidden files
we can use these as attack vectors all
right so as I said it also allows you to
find hidden directories or files that
hidden from the public so this can also
lead you to to finding additional
resources that could have been hid in a
way by the devs that like for example
admin pages etc etc alright so how does
it work well really simply once you
start up the Buster and again as I
mentioned it uses brute-forcing so I'll
explain where word lists come into play
so you open it up and you select the URL
of the web application or the web site
and you specify the port the port is
there is definitely going to be HTTP so
either a port 80 or port 443 and then
you select the word list no in this case
Kali Linux already has a busta word list
that that are designed it has three of
them that are designed for different
types of scenarios and I'll explain them
as we move along all right and
essentially how it works is once you
start the brute force attack it will
send HTTP GET requests and it will wait
for the response from the server or the
web the web application if it gets a 200
spawns that means that yes that
directory exists all right if it get if
it gets a bad response meaning like 400
or 403 meaning no access then it'll it
will it will know that that directory or
file doesn't exist so it's essentially
testing directories on the server
against this this word list so it will
check for example is there a temp folder
if it sends a temp request to the server
it gets a response a positive response
then it knows it's there and then it
will enumerate them alright so let's
start off really simply Assam on Cali
the next I have the OS broken web
application right here and I'm going to
be demonstrating a two scenario so you
can see I'm running that here and that
has a lot of vulnerable web applications
but the whole idea is to demonstrate how
directories can be found all right and
why this is extremely important
especially for a web application
penetration tester all right so I'm
gonna put up Firefox and as you can see
I have the open web application project
right here the OSB web as they call it
and it has plenty of of ways of me
testing this but what if I was to just
test the entire server alright so this
is a web server what if I was to test
the entire web server well I'm guessing
that there going to be a lot of files
and directories so what we can do is we
can start off with a perfect example of
how this would work is let's say you're
targeting a wordpress site so I'm going
to open up the broken WordPress and of
course this is a very old one and we're
not really exploiting anything but by
using this example it will let us
understand how we can enumerate the
different directories and folders you
know on this WordPress installation or
if you were target targeting a wordpress
site this is the way you do it so I'm
going to copy the URL with the with the
directory right here so it's we know
it's in the WordPress folder because
that is the root directory of the of the
web server and we are selecting the
WordPress installation but for the web
site
you will select the URL alright and
that's for the port we know that this is
the default HTTP port which means it's
port 80 all right so I have der burst
right here if you can't find it just you
can use the Start menu and type in Busta
it's going to be like so just this
click on it and give it a few seconds to
start up so again it was designed by the
OS team so it works really really well
and again this is something that I'm
sure if you if you are a web application
penetration tester or you do do the CTF
challenges then you'll you'll know that
you use this tool a lot alright so we in
here we have the target URL and that's
where we will paste it all right so we
can paste it right here so control V and
that is the URL now in the work method
if you want to if you want the scan to
be faster you can use the get requests
but what we can do is auto switch them
from the head and get and that will give
us a more robust or a more accurate
response rate alright so in terms of the
number of thirds this is how fast you
want you want the scan or the brute
force to be so the faster the better
depending on your hardware and of course
you don't want to overload this server
so I'm just gonna go hit click on go
faster that probably works the best for
me but if you want it to run faster then
that means it's gonna it's gonna have
multiple requests and threats being sent
from your computer alright so I like
keeping it at just 200 threads which is
go faster and because I'm testing my own
web server I can you know I can pretty
much increase it to whatever I want so
usually if you're talking about a bigger
server or a bigger web application then
you it doesn't really matter how many
requests or how many threads you use it
will not really affect the performance
of the web server but evolves to run it
at maybe a maximum speed you'd see that
the web server would be lagging out you
know out of the amount of requests that
are being sent because you know you have
to understand it from a fundamental
point of view we are requesting the
different web pages and the server has
to process them so if the if the if the
server is not running on on you know
good resources like it's running on one
gigabyte of ram it's very easy to make
it like out and to actually cause some
sort of a denial of service just because
of the amount of requests but in this
case we are performing it you know with
with an ethical perspective so now you
want to select a list based brute force
or you can use a pure brute force but I
don't recommend that that doesn't really
work and you no need to select your word
list your
Buster wordlist now by default on kali
linux and on parrot OS these are found
in this user share folder on the under
word list and you can find the the busta
word list right there so i'm going to
show you that right now so i'm gonna
browse i'm gonna go to my root and i'm
gonna go into user and i'm going to go
into share and let's go into word lists
here let's see if i can find it it's
obviously with aw where it where is it
let's see let's see let's see where is
word lists sorry if i can't see this
there there we are sorry about that word
lists and you now want to go into der
buster alright so there is going to be a
folder called der buster and now you
might be a little bit confused well
really you don't need to need need to be
confused that's why i'm here so as a
beginner you might be wondering like
which one is better now as an advanced
penetration test i know which one is the
best in most cases it's going to be the
medium the directory list 2.3 medium dot
txt now if you're scanning a very small
web application that that's not that
really complex like a simple HTML site
you know HTML CSS whatever you want to
call it then I would recommend this
small one but if you're scanning a a big
site like a WordPress installation or a
Joomla installation then you should use
the medium one this will work 99% of the
time unless your your your requests are
being blocked by either a web
application firewall or by the the host
so I'm just gonna it's select list
alright and now in terms of these other
options you can see it's it's going to
essentially brute brute force slick
directories the files it's going to be
recursive which is great and the
directory you must specify the directory
if it is if you are trying to perform a
scan that is directory sensitive all
right and standard start point just
leave it like that and you now want to
hit start all right so once you start
his gonna start brute forcing the
webserver against its gonna start
sending the requests and if it gets the
responses the positive responses is
going to is going to understand that yes
that directory does exist now you can
see we have a response that is being
sent here and it's going to tell tell
you that it is unable to determine a
consistent failed response which means
some directories and
are being you're getting a negative or
you're getting no access response
meaning that that directory doesn't
exist so what you can do is just hit
cancel to these zones in ATS and it's
going to continue scanning the other
ones no of course down here you can see
since it's performing a brute force you
can look at the current speed which
varies dependent on the amount of
directories the average speed and it'll
tell you the total amount of requests
done out of the amount that could be
done depending on on the word list that
you have selected and finally you have
the time to finish and of course this
will vary dependent on a lot of factors
but mostly it depends on the the the
speed of the scan that you've selected
and the and the word list so you have
your scan information here it's gonna
tell you what are folders and files it's
testing and in here you can see the
results in terms of directories and
files that it was able to find and in
the results it this is going to give you
the directory structure as to how files
and folders are being structured on the
web application now by default right now
you can see the amount the files and
folders that it has found are for
example the wordpress register dot PHP
so if we open that if you right click on
it you can open it in the URL or you can
view the response that it gave and you
can copy it you understand you get the
basic functionality here and then you
can open it in your browser so again you
see that we are finding files that we
otherwise wouldn't have known existed
now of course for a default WordPress
installation you would have guessed that
this does exist but remember most people
are revoking for most other
installations on configure figurations
this can be a great way of finding files
and folders that you didn't know existed
and again discovering them is very very
important and this can give you
different attack vectors for for example
if I went to the admin dot PHP and it
forced me to login that might be a good
place to start root forcing if I had
credentials if not you can choose select
another attack vector so let me just
move back here you can see we have the
register page here which we just clicked
on let's look at the wordpress login dot
PHP so I'm going to open that up in the
browser now you can see the server is
not responding and that's another point
that I wanted to point out if you want
to be as
right now we are being as promiscuous as
possible because it's not really a web
application that is delivering service
to other people but because it's hosted
on my local area network so in this case
you can do a performing a type of denial
of service and that's because the server
I've allocated very very minimal
resources to this virtual machine so
that's why it's kind of lagging out all
right so that's something to take into
consideration now files to to pause the
attack like so first to just posit
remember you can pause it and you can
stop it and let me just go back here and
let's see if we can reload these pages
they should be able to to be reloaded a
quick enough let me let me just load
that up and we can close this one let's
see if the WordPress register page does
open up
if this virtual yeah there we are so you
can see even though this is a very old
WordPress installation that we were
causing it to lag out so always keep
that in mind that the amount of threads
that you said can affect the performance
of the website of or of the web
application and you don't want to cause
any any impact to customers if you're
performing the test on a real world
working web application or website
alright just something you might want to
take into consideration so we're gonna
resume it and of course I'm not going to
expect to find anything weird here
although this WordPress installation is
designed to be vulnerable so you can
also change the number of threads
running right here so if I wanted it to
run you know maybe on 10 threads which
is quite slow that means you'll get the
enumeration process will take longer so
it's all about balancing your resources
and understanding what you're trying to
look for you know of course this can be
a very very useful tool when doing bug
bounties or or CTF for that matter
especially hack the box
we are going to be looking at
extremely important and something that
should be understood completely and that
is cross-site scripting all right now
before we get started I'm just gonna
explain what we're gonna be looking at
explain what we're gonna be looking at
in this video we're gonna start off with
explaining what cross-site scripting is
I'm gonna be showing you the environment
that we'll be using for testing any of
these any of these attacks just because
they allow us to illustrate or they
allow me to explain how everything works
because that's the most important thing
for me is that you understand what
you're you're listening to and you have
a good representation of what's going on
alright so I'll be explaining stored
I'll be explaining the reflected stored
and Dom cross-site scripting alright so
let's get started with me explaining
what environment I'm currently running
so you can see that I'm running Kali
Linux right now but I am going to be
using the OS a broken web applications
project so I'll have this in the
description section it is essentially a
virtual machine that you can easily just
run on VirtualBox or VMware I'm
currently running it here as you can see
I just got the local IP it's 192 point
one sixty eight point one point one one
one alright so I have it at running and
I'm running this on Kali Linux and I
already have opened up the URL in my
browser so you can see from here I've
opened up B web and I've opened up
webgoat because that's what I'm going to
be using to explain each of these
cross-site scripting attacks so if I was
to do that first to just open up one
ninety two point one sixty eight point
one point one on-one
yours could be different it should be
different depending on your IP
configuration and subnet then it'll take
you to the OS bwa or the OS broken web
applications project the latest version
as of recording this video is version
1.2 so we will be using webgoat and be
web of the broken web application
project for for this demonstration so
the default credentials for webgoat are
going to be guest for the username and
guest for the password and for be web it
should give you
prompt right over there I think it's
going to be a bug app or something like
that but irregardless it will tell you
what it is alright so make sure you open
that up and you have that all set up so
I've logged in to be web and I have a
web goat started up right here alright
so let me close that up and we are ready
to go now before we even move on into
performing these attacks it's very
important to understand what's going on
here with with cross-site scripting what
it is how it works and what are you
exactly taking advantage of all right
now this is where a lot of people make
mistakes and if you want to be a
successful web application penetration
tester you'll need to understand you
know from a fundamental level what's
going on here all right so let's get
started what is cross side scripting
well simply put it is the process of
injecting a script into a into the
parameter in url to attack a user of the
site or to potentially attack the server
side of the website or the web
application right so it essentially is
the inject the injection of a script
into the parameter of a URL
all right that's essentially what it is
now of course this may be quite
confusing but don't worry I'll explain
what's going on here so let's start off
with with first of all explaining the
three types of cross-site scripting all
right the first one is reflected and
then we have stored and Dom so with
reflected what's happening here is the
the data is input it and then you know
reflected directly back back on the
screen so I'll explain this in a second
all right so if we are to look at this
from a fundamental perspective I'll show
you how to access this you know how to
navigate be web just give me a second
let me explain what's going on so
essentially what's happening with
reflected cross-site scripting is that
the input is going to be stored in the
parameter of the URL all right and I'll
explain how this differs with each type
of attack because many of you will point
out and say well it's not only to do
with parameters and don't worry I'll
explain all of this all right so we can
essentially manipulate the parameter of
the URL so that we can essentially run a
script now what type of script we can
run
delicious script that is based in
JavaScript and I'll explain that right
now so you can see with our portal you
don't want to touch anything here you
can set the security level but for now I
recommend setting it too low not that
that's going to hurt anyone's ego
because remember you have to be humble
to begin and you need to understand
what's going on first so we will open up
the choose the bug section here and we
want to go down into cross-site
scripting and we want to go into
reflected which essentially deals with
the get the get requests so we're going
to start off with that and this will
really make you understand what's going
on here so if I click on that and I just
hit hack alright so now it's gonna give
us a prompt here and you might be asking
well what's what do you mean what
exactly is going on if I was to not
enter any details into the you know into
these fields right here so for example
you can see I just had a suggestion
there that's because I was testing it
out but it was to hit go you can see
that in the URL we do have the input
here so you can see the values can be
edited directly into the form so you can
see first name has the no value and then
we have the last name which again has no
value and you can see that it is
submitting a form so what we can do is
run some JavaScript code in here and the
most common way of one of explaining
what's going on here of course not
running a very malicious code right now
it's essentially explaining and
demonstrating that it does work is I can
run a piece of code here now of course
when you put this into a practical
perspective many sites are going to
filter the content that you can enter in
these fields or these forms and will
essentially will not allow you to run
JavaScript code you know obviously to
protect to protect the site from these
type of attacks but what you can do is
encapsulate it to encode it in a
different type of language or as I said
I'll show you everything
or how all of this works so this write
right now being the current security
level as low we it'll not ill not
essentially encode it will not verify or
validate what we're entering in here
what input is being give
so if we were to type in a script here
so you can say script and you can see
the recommendation there script that's
mine so if also type in alert and this
is JavaScript so I'm pretty I am pretty
sure you can you know what's going on so
you can see hello world this is an
example of reflective XSS or cross-site
scripting and we can close that up right
now and then we need to close the script
so you can do that in the next field or
the next parameter most people like
doing it from the start but this is just
to show you how robust this can be so I
type in I close the script there and I
hit go and as you can see it gives us
the alert which is what we and we which
is what we used as our form of of me
showing you that it does work and it
will be processed the input will be
processed and will be sent back to you
you've been the client and we can just
hit OK and that was an example of
reflected excess cross-site scripting
using the get method now of course we
can I can replicate this many many times
using the other types of cross-site
scripting for example with the post etc
etc we'll be looking at all of that but
for now we need to understand what's
going on here now next we need to look
at a stored
cross-site scripting this is probably my
favorite because of the potential that
it does have all right so let's go into
the choose your bug menu here and we
want to go into cross-site scripting and
we want to go we want to go for the blog
cross-site scripting stored cross-site
scripting and we're gonna select block
and I'll explain why in a second alright
so first let me explain what stored
cross-site scripting is so essentially
with this with the cross-site scripting
attacks more specifically the stored
attacks essentially what's happening is
you're attacking the input and you're
essentially attacking the input that is
to be stored or you're attacking the
data or essentially I'll explain this
really simply so you're attacking the
input that is to be stored on a database
so what you're doing is you're
essentially injecting malicious code
that will be saved into a database or
that is going to be saved by the server
or the web application server and then
you can
definitely you since it's being stored
you can access it later on or other
users can access it and for example if
it's running malicious code it can
trigger different things like opening
the webcam of a user stealing different
type of information I'm not going to go
into what you can do with it but you can
really do a lot of stuff a lot of
malicious stuff with code all right so
let me explain what's going on here so
with the stored cross-site scripting you
can essentially inject malicious code
into the database again that then that
when accessed runs this malicious code
alright so if you can see this is an
example of a block let me explain what I
mean the best places to implement stored
cross-site scripting is in places like
comments you know forums and again as
you can see right here blog in the form
of comments that you know or pages that
can be accessed later or data that is
being stored in directly into the
database any database for that matter as
long as it's being stored okay so we can
type in here something like hello and we
can submit that to the database and you
can see it's getting stored and you have
different tables you have the the number
the owner the date and the entry so now
we can also run a script in here alright
so what if we were to enter a JavaScript
and again this data given our security
level is any of the data that we're
entering is not being validated so you
can essentially enter it raw now in
reality if you go and try and enter
script in the data will not be accepted
because again they are protecting their
site against that that's one way of
mitigation very basic I'm sure you know
what I'm talking about
all right so enough of me rambling on so
if we are doing enter the same script we
entered so we were to say script and we
then say alert for example we can you
can use any type of JavaScript code you
want here and you can experiment you
know you these web applications are
there for you to experiment and test
your skills out so first to say hello
world this is stored stored
cross-site scripting and we just close
that up there and of course we have to
close the script because we know that
that will not execute if we do not code
it
correctly okay so now we can we can add
that and if I was to just hit submit
right now you can see that it's going to
store and be that being the latest blog
post you can see it's gonna tell you
it's gonna execute the script and it's
gonna say hello world this is stored
across site scripting so and an example
of a block if you are to post this on a
page or a you know to make a blog post
and inject this script in anyone opens
that page will essentially run that
malicious code and whatever that code
does can then furthermore you know cause
damage to the user or to the server
depending on what you want it to do so
it's all dependent on what the attacker
is to do remember what I told you in the
first video of this series it's all
about your mindset and your your your
willingness to break things and to find
out what does and doesn't work okay so
that was an example of stored cross-site
scripting and as I've mentioned the most
important thing to understand is this in
this scenario the data is not being
validated if it is being validated and
I'll show you that in a second or
probably in the next set of videos will
increase the security level and I'll
show you how to get you know past this
you can see how things change as you
move along in terms of security levels
so I was going to use the bwak are this
my first time using it so I had to get a
bit of an introduction through the
documentation and I realized they don't
have Dom cross-site scripting so I
that's why I had to use webgoat they're
the only ones I know who actually allow
us to run it so sumed in right now by
the way the credentials our guest for
the username and guest for the password
so essentially I went through cross-site
scripting and again they didn't have the
the Dom in here all they were focusing
on is stored and again reflected so I
found it to be in the iyx or Ajax or tau
whatever you want to call it and we have
deal the Dom based cross-site scripting
let me explain why it's saying this is
based in a at security this is because
Dom cross-site scripting focuses on the
client-side so any data or input that is
that whether it be a malicious code etc
etc is going to be processed by the
client not the server so any of the
attacks will be based of course on the
client now let me explain what I mean if
I am to run remember JavaScript
server-side client-side I ax for example
so if I am to run for example a
JavaScript code in this entry here so
script and again I type in alert just
being the example and I say hello let's
keep that simple and I close the script
here you can see that we will probably
not be left with anything will not get
any result that's because it's being
processed by the client not by the
server so no no result or no data will
be reflected back to us if it was you
know if it was reflected cross-site
scripting it the server processes it and
then is reflected back to the client so
first to submit here you can see that
nothing happens here and that it is
going to be taken as good now what if we
were to enter or use a language that
that a client can understand so let's
say we were to to say let's see HTML
what if or to use HTML so I can say in
here I am G for example that's a very
this is the way we learnt it so I am G
SRC and we don't have an image source so
we can leave that like that and then we
can use the on error in case we get an
error of image which we will get because
the image has no source on error we can
say that is going to be that is going to
be equal to alert and then the alert we
can then put in here we can say hello
whoops hello world and we can close that
up and once you have closed it you can
see that we can we can close that there
and there you are so it is going to be
processed by the client and you get the
the dialog box or the alert with the
message helloworld so you can see that
with Dom based cross-site scripting it
is all being processed all the input
whether it be malicious or not is being
processed by the client and ax is one of
the laddies languages that can be used
so you can also incorporate a ax if you
wanted to or test it out remember
all about experimentation and
understanding I hope that you've got an
understanding of what cross-site
scripting is how it can be used to
manipulate data whether it be on the
client-side on the database and now you
can easily just transfer data with you
know bad security in place of course
this is these attacks will be very
uncommon now but again this was focused
on more on on an explanation point of
view
you are going to be looking at
request forgery or CSRF now this is an
extremely important topic and a big one
that I cover it correctly so for the
purpose of this video I've set up a very
unique environment that in at least in
my opinion will demonstrate how to
utilize or how to perform this attack
all right now I'm just gonna give you a
brief overview of the environment that I
have no of course you can see I have a
few files open here don't worry about
them right now just just remember that
we'll be using them later on and I'll be
using them really really well to explain
what's going on here so you can see as
my target or as my vulnerable system I'm
going to be using my vulnerable web
application I should say I'm going to be
using the OS juice shop now not actually
no one actually recommended this to me
but I remember that I performed this
during a CTF challenge that I went to
earlier I think late last year I'm not
too sure exactly when but the old
process was involved with exploiting
this web application all right and in my
opinion this really outlined or really
showed of how to perform all of these
various web application attacks in this
case we're going to be focusing on
cross-site request forgery all right so
I have the juice shop running it's it's
based on nodejs and running on my local
host let me just show you that right now
there we are so I haven't logged in or
done anything yet and that's because I'm
going to do that with you so I've set it
up it's running on my local host let's
get started with this really really
simple but sometimes complicated topic
all right so cross-site request forgery
CSRF now from the name you can already
tell that it's split into two into two
sections you have your cross-site and
your request forgery so from that we can
get a basic example of what's going on
here we have cross-site scripting and we
are going to be forging requests or we
are going to be manipulating requests
mmm interesting so we are we are kind of
understanding what's going on here now
the technical explanation for what CSRF
is is it is an attack that forces an end
user
- executed unwanted actions on a web
application in which they are currently
authenticated all right so let me put
that really really simply right it it's
an attack that will force an end user to
execute unwanted actions on our on our
web application these actions can be
anything but in this case we're going to
be looking at changing the password and
they have to be currently authenticated
to that web application to it which
means they have to be logged in to that
web application for this to work because
if they are logged out then you get the
idea it really doesn't help for it
doesn't work all right so we use
cross-site scripting in this case to
perform the request forgery and to get
either desired or undesired results in
our case we're going to be looking at
how to to change the password of any
user that's logged in to the to this web
application and how will we how will we
be doing that well we are going to be
using CSS arrived but the first thing
you need to understand is how an HTML
form works all right and this is very
important because first of all a client
will request a page from a server all
right the server will then respond and
give the des client the HTML form the
client will then send back the form with
the data back to the server the server
will then authenticate and authorize the
user and then will will perform the
requested action and based on the
request and the response we are able to
forge or to change the request and get a
desired response if you're looking at it
from an attackers perspective alright so
the the way CRS CS CSRF works sorry
about that
is the attacker will manipulate the
victim into submitting the attackers
form data to the victims web server
essentially essentially performing these
these requests and in our case as I've
mentioned it will allow us to change the
password of any user on this web
application in this case the OS juice
shop web application alright so now you
might be asking well if I'm a bug bounty
hunter Aurra I'm practicing to become a
bug bounty hunter
how do I go about finding this
vulnerability well that's a very good
question and that is the question you
should be asking yourself when
performing any penetration test now
coming back to my environment I'm
running burp suite the community edition
you you'll just need the Community
Edition for this one we're not
performing any advanced techniques here
because we're essentially just changing
we're just going to be changing the
requests to get our desired responses
but once we move on to the advanced
stuff I'll then be using OS zap for our
attacks all right so keeping things
really really simple we the way to look
for these vulnerabilities is to target
the login pages which we have right here
we then need to we can then create the
account and login and then finally we
will be creating our own our own script
to perform the cross-site scripting and
that will allow us to submit the data or
if we send the URL to another user of
this web application who is currently
authenticated it will allow their it
will allow us to make them change their
password and then we can log in to their
account
alright so this vulnerability is very
common on sites with accounts you know
sites that have emails a passwords and
as you probably would have guessed there
are a lot of sites that utilize this
functionality but remember most of the
sites out there will be protected from
this vulnerability so it's up to you to
find these vulnerabilities alright so as
I've mentioned we will be using OS brew
shop as our target and the reason is is
because it will explain what I want to
explain really really well all right and
we'll be using the burp suite Community
Edition now as you can see I'm currently
running the burp proxy
I'm not intercepting any traffic if I
open up burp suite
I'm not intercepting any traffic if I go
to the proxy and intercept I'm not
intercepting anything so it's currently
just I'm just going through the proxy
and all traffic and data is being logged
through the proxy so when it comes down
to this little data that I've saved here
I've already created an account the
reason I've done that is to save time
because I don't want to explain
everything about it so I've create I've
created a user with the email of tests
at test com
and a password of password so really
simple again there's nothing really
complicated here and if you want if
you're wondering what exactly does this
mean well this is a security question
with the answer so the question was
what's my favorite pet and I wrote in
dog
so hopefully that doesn't scare you into
thinking that I've gone completely crazy
and then in here we have this script
that we'll be using or will be utilizing
to perform the CSRF on the site I'll get
to this in a second we don't need that
right now so if I want to log in I know
that the the email is test a test comm
and the password is password all right
so let me do that right now we need to
authenticate so let me log in like so
and I'm gonna hit test at test comm all
right and I'm going to write the
password which is password and I'm gonna
eat login all right and I'm don't want
to save the password and there you are
so I've logged in now now as I said this
is very this vulnerability works really
really well when you're talking about
changing passwords because as you can
probably guess an attacker would would
be looking to exploit this functionality
because imagine if we were able to send
a request a get request to our target
with the URL encoded URL of course we
can also use link shorteners if we
wanted to do that and essentially if
they authenticated it it will allow us
to make them change their password
simply by clicking on the link changing
the password to whatever we specify all
right so how do we do this well the
first thing we need to do is we need to
look at how they get requests are being
sent and we can do that using burp so
we're just going to change our password
so our current password is password and
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
change my password into password oops
sorry
password 1 2 3 and I'm going to repeat
it so fast word 1 2 3 and I'm gonna
change alright so the password was
successfully changed ok now let's look
at how this was processed in burp or how
the request was sent in but so I'm going
to go into burp our proxy and HTTP
history and I'm gonna go all the way to
the bottom and as you can see we have
the get request right over here
ok so the get request is
interesting you can see we have the get
request and it's dog eating the the
following URL and these are the
parameters so change password the
current password is password new
password one two three and we've
repeated it all right so now let us
perform the forgery here so I'm gonna
send this in to the repeater alright so
I'm gonna click on repeater and in here
we can manipulate the request and see
what responses we get all right in case
you did not know about that but again
let's start off really really simply so
we are going to be working with the raw
request we don't want to work with
individual parameters although you could
change it but we are going to be
manipulating the request entirely so
that it performs what we want to do
alright so what we can do first is we
can test so let's change what if we were
to change the current password to
something like let's see test let's
change it to test and then we hit go you
can see that the response we get is a is
a 401 error which means we are
authorized to make that and it will give
you the message right here the current
password is not correct all right that's
good that is good from a web application
perspective which means that this web
application is performing validation and
it's not going to allow us to you know
to just go in and start manipulating any
requests and making changes so from a
security perspective the web application
is doing really well
all right what if I was to change the
new password let me change this back to
password to the current password which
is what we said and I changed the new
password - password pass one two three
all right and I hit go again we get
another run again the 401 unauthorized
error telling us that the new and
repeated password do not match so yes
the current password is correct and the
only thing that we are getting an error
is the new password and the repeated
password are not correct so interesting
what if we want to change the password
into password one two three and we can
repeat that again so we want to confirm
this so password one two three actually
hold on so I'm gonna say
password 1 2 3 and now let's see what
this tells us this should verify it but
let's see if this works so you can see
yes that does work and we know that this
works because that's what we did that
was the original request but what if we
do not know the current password of the
user remember we're going to be
targeting other users of this web
application so what if we get rid off
and this is very very this is the way
peer penetration testers go about it
what if we get rid of stuff so what if
we get rid of the current password all
right and now essentially the get is
targeting change password with the
question mark here essentially
requesting and we are only entering the
fields or parameters new and repeat what
if we do that and we change them to
password 1 2 3
I mean passed 1 2 3 and pass 1 2 3 let
me it go you can see yes it does work we
get the 200 the 200 response which means
everything was processed correctly and
we were able to get a password that
looks to be hash that looks to be hashed
and we got the email that we used so yes
we do know that it is working all right
so we know that we know that this worked
but we need to confirm that this has
worked so we can do this by going back
into our web application and we can log
out and we can try and log in again so
log in with our new password so we're
gonna say test at test comm and our new
password was passed 1 2 3 remember we we
changed it earlier but again I was
demonstrating that if we are to send
this to our target we need to specify
that it will work without any free
required information like their current
password so if manipulated the Rae
request there so let's hit login and
voila you can see it does work excellent
all right so this is a fantastic example
of CSRF can be utilized or how it can be
X how you can find vulnerabilities for
it all right so this can allow us to
change or update anyone's password
anyone's accounts password that are
currently logged into this web
application all right so now what do we
know what we need to do well
we can login as we've already seen we
can login and once you've logged in we
can we can test to see if cross-site
scripting does work and then of course
utilizing it throughout the web
application is very important so we can
run a simple cross-site script attack to
see if it will work on this search bar
right here so I'm going to type in
script and a simple one so alert just to
test whether it works and in the alert
we can say hello just something stupid
hello world
you know that's and I can't even type
man come on world and we have typed in
the alert and we can finally close this
script here script like so and let's hit
search and voila we can see that indeed
cross-site scripting what works which
means we can insert we can insert our
our get request inside the script and
and use a cross-site scripting to
perform the CSRF and now you can see
them conjoining together cross-site
scripting with request forgery okay so
we now need to create our custom script
that will allow us to utilize the attack
and we will be using XML and HTTP now
you might have seen this script right
over here let me just minimize this and
open up leafpad you might have seen this
script that I created now you can find
many of these csrs scripts are online
that utilize different languages in my
case I find the one that works the best
is the is one that works with XML and
HTTP and contains the get request in
here ok now you can see that the get
request requires the URL in which we
submit the parameters without the
current password so we need to go back
into book and once to go back in to
proxy HTTP sorry about the HTTP we look
to change the password here so if we go
back into sorry the repeater and if we
look at this now we can see that the URL
is right over here
so that's the get request so if we copy
this the localhost obviously and we are
not using any current password field so
if we can do that really simply you can
see how this can butyl
really really well so what we need to do
now is understand how the URL will be
format and of course the web application
is going to encode it and I'll get to
that in a second so we need to copy this
URL right here so I'm just going to copy
the URL and we can edit our whole script
so HTTP and we paste it in inside the
URL you can copy this script if you want
to let's take a look at whether this
script is formatted correctly so get
HTTP new that's not the way we want it
let me get rid of the pre pre determined
HTTP there so HTTP localhost it's hosted
on my localhost with the port 3,000 note
no dia standard and the we want to
change the password the new password is
passed one two three and repeat is
passed one two three you can change that
to whatever you want if you want to you
know play around with a script but in my
case I don't want to do any of that so
this is the script so what we can do is
we can copy this now and we can run this
in the search bar and that should in
theory and in practice give us our first
CSRF attack on the site so I'm gonna
paste this in here and let's see whether
it does this so I'm gonna it's search
and you can see you successfully soft
solve the challenge error handling
provoke an error that is not very
gracefully handle again this is a
fantastic web application vulnerable web
application that is awesome for
practicing your your web application
penetration testing skills now I talked
about the URL that you should send to
your target and that is the URL that
will essentially make them change their
password or without them knowing given
that they are logged in to the web
application or the oven account it will
not work if they have not logged in all
right so that's very important to
understand and many people just you know
forget about this now again if you you
could have done this you I can log out
again and I can log in try and log in
now and I can type in for example test I
just want to show you something very
interesting your test and I can change
the password we already changed it to
password one two three now before I do
that I can just in
back to the element here and I'm gonna
eat login and I just want you to check
something out right now let me just
expand this a little bit here if we were
to look at the network this will
essentially show us all the get requests
so I first to hit login you can see that
if we are to look at the get request
here the login get requests you can go
ahead and look at at the exact format in
which it was sent you can look at the
cookie the it should give you the the
authentication token not too sure it
should give you the authentic the
authentication token but that's
something for another day I don't want
to complicate you guys you can look at
the cookie if you want to and you have
all the responses right here so there we
are there's the authentication token and
you can see something very interesting
in regards to the token all right so let
me show you this right now all right so
as I was saying you can see all right so
as I was saying you can see that if we
look at the parameters the password will
be displayed then it will be updated to
the one that we selected or specified in
the script all right so remember if you
want to customize the cross-site
scripting attack you can do it through
your script and where is leafpad here so
there we are so you can change the
password the as you see we just got rid
of the current password parameter which
is a vulnerability on the site but you
can change the positive to whatever you
want and now you might be asking as I've
mentioned what link do you send to the
target and that is very very simple if I
was to run the script again and I
changed the posture to maybe something
else like password 1 2 4 or 3 4 5 sorry
3 4 5 let me just add that to the
password and I run the script on an
authenticated user which is me so let me
copy that and it should change my
account password and you can see once I
log at logout and try logging in it will
have changed it successfully so let me
just run it in here so I'm going to
paste the new one in here and I'm going
to search and there we are so now it's
changed my password and if I log out and
I try and log in with with the old
password which is password 1 2 3
you can see whoops sorry I think I typed
that in wrongly one two three like so
fight login there we are you can see
that we added the new password and it
did work fantastic so we were
successfully able to execute the script
and again one if I just run the script
again this is the URL that you will send
to your target all right so if I just
copy it and I inspect it in my leafpad
here I really love leaf but I don't know
that you guys love it too if I just
inspect it you can see that this indeed
is a URL and if the web application was
being hosted on a server outside my
local air network it would give you the
website name the port if it is put
specific and the URL here which as you
can see is encoded so what I would
recommend is that you copy this link
here and you use a link shortener like
bit fly or any of the other Google
shorteners and you send that to your
target and once they click on the link
and if they already logged in to this
specific web application it will update
their password and you can essentially
you have their password now because
you've updated it and you all all you
need is the email which I'm pretty sure
you must be knowing if you're performing
this attack or you could just be
gathering passwords of users or of which
you can you can send this link to and
are authenticated with the web
application
we're going to be taking a look at
session
and in this video particularly we'll be
looking at cookie collection alright so
as you know you probably would have
known what a cookie is now there are
three types of cookies that we really
need to be focusing on in this section
and we'll be focusing on in general the
first one is the session cookies which
I'll discuss in a while we then have the
permanent cookies and the third party
cookies so third party cookies are
really all to do with third party API so
that may be used so for example if
you're on our website that utilizes
Flash Player you may find some cookies
that that are in in relate that are
related to the Flash Player so it's very
important that you understand how to
collect these cookies and as well we'll
be looking at reverse engineering them
but not really tampering with them
because of I first want to explain to
you guys how everything is done and then
we can move on into into finally
tampering with them and seeing if we can
change them to give us access to give a
different type of of access and where
this comes into place when they're
talking about session cookies and in
this session cookies we have the the
auth the authentication token and the D
and the unauthenticated token so all to
do with your access on a web application
or on a website okay so essentially all
the cookies that you can probably ever
get when you visit are you you get when
you visit a website are they are
generated when you visit the website and
furthermore the cookies change when
you're authenticated with the website
and you or you log out alright so when
you log in you get a different set of
cookies and when you log out you get a
different set of cookies this is where
the whole idea of session management
comes into play and how cookies are
utilized for this system so I'm
currently running OS new shop so I
showed you guys how to set that up let
me know if you found it helpful so I
have it set it up and open I have it
opened up in my browser now what I'm
gonna be covering is how to collect
these cookies and understanding the
difference between an unauthenticated
cookie and the authenticated cookie so
you
what I have water used to my advantage
is if you're using Google Chrome or
Firefox you you can get a cookie
collection or a cookie editor add-on
that allows you to edit the cookies but
they said we're not going to be looking
at editing them right now because we
don't know what to change in them this
video is going to be focused on
collecting them and then analyzing them
to see what information they have within
them all right so I've currently I reset
this the OS juice shop and the reason I
did that is just to start off fresh and
I said we're going to be using this for
performing all of the examples that I'll
be showing you so that we can learn all
the concepts so I'm just gonna but
before we log in I just want to show you
the first set of cookies that we'll get
once we when we visit at the site don't
worry about the other links we'll get to
them in a second all right so I'm using
the cookie editor right here you can
find this same one for Firefox that's
what I'm using
they are also other ones for google
chrome if you want to do that and in
addition we're not going to be using any
proxy like burp suite or the OS app
right now because we're just focused on
using the browser tools and of course
these add-ons here so what I can do now
is fighter school right-click and I hit
inspect element we have the the
developer tools right here and if we are
to go into once you've installed the
cookie editor you can directly go into
storage and in storage you'll be give
you get the cookies here and other
values right here but if you it'll be
better for you to understand what's
going on if you go into the cookie
editor now in the cookie editor you can
see that we have two cookies that we've
gathered DM you have the cookie consent
status and the the IO which I'm not sure
really what it does input out in our
output on probably guessing so when it
comes down to the cookie consent status
we probably get an idea of what of what
this is of what this is asking us so
when I when I opened up the website it
gave me a prompt asking me like all
websites will ask you in 2018 to do is
to accept their privacy policy in their
privacy policies in regards to the use
of personal date
and cookies and the reason is is because
cookies can can look or have a lot of
information about you they contain a lot
of information about what your what
you've been doing so this is why I've
created this right now before we move
along it's very important to understand
their role in session management okay so
we need to look at the authentic the
authentication tokens because that's
where most of the magic happens as you
would expect so let me just close this
up and let me just login so let me just
use the password there the email that I
used and the password like so and let me
just login I don't want to save the
password so I've logged in now and if I
inspect the element again you can see in
the cookie editor let that load it
usually takes a while to load there we
are we have the token now the token this
token is an authentication token all
right so when it comes down when it
comes down to reverse engineering a
token for example let's use this as our
example we're essentially testing it for
vulnerability similar to a penetration
test now you might be a little bit
confused you might be asking well what
what what do you mean by this how can we
perform a penetration test on this token
well this token is encoded all right so
this is if we just copy this I don't
know whether you know about this but
this is a JSON web token alright so it
is it is a JSON web token and you can
use the JSON web token a decoder I'll be
posting this link in the description
this is the one that I prefer to use if
I am to paste this in here and you can
see but once I've pasted it in here it's
going to give me all information and I'm
gonna help you understand what we've
just done so essentially what we have
done is we have reverse-engineered what
this web token is all about so now we
need to look at what what it contains
and what type of authorities or
privileges is giving to us because
remember this is an authentication token
and it is unique to us because this will
air this will determine whether or not
we are logged into a site or we're
logged out and what access we have on
the website I'm pretty sure you already
know that all right so when it comes to
the header now this is very important
I've seen many web people claiming to be
bug bounty hunters and they don't
understand how the the
dokin is even structured what is the
header the head a separated from the
payload this is the header right here up
until the first full stop that is the
heads very important to understand that
because they are separated from each
other
in fact the JSON web token is sorted
into three parts right here you have the
e of the header you then have the
payload until here and then finally you
have the signature which is right right
at the bottom here which is also
separated from the rest okay so when it
comes down to the header
all right the header is going to give
you the type of the of the token and in
this case we know it's a JSON web token
we then have the algorithm which is the
hashing algorithm used which is the RS
256 and then the payload now in the
payload this is where things get really
interesting as you would have expected
you have the status the status code here
the data if any data was passed the ID
we can always use the ID - we can always
edit the ID to see what else it can give
us in terms of authentication because
different types of identifications or
identification tokens give us different
types of access so as essentially this
is what I was talking about this is
where you will scrutinize the the
authentication token and try and and
tamper with it - to see what different
results you can you can get so remember
we can edit this token all right and we
can edit anything about it and then we
can finally copy it and we can use that
in the US view shop and paste it right
here andrey authenticate with that new
token and see what results we can get
and of course we are not going to do
that right now because I wanted to
introduce you as to what information
you're gonna find and what exactly is
going on here okay so one step at a time
so you can see that something
interesting props up here something
extremely interesting we have the email
which for some reason in this token we
can see that it's not very well designed
because the email is in plain text which
means which means if in any case or in
any scenario someone is is able to get
this token in which I authenticated
within a site they will have access to
my email
my password but you must be saying well
I didn't see you type out all of these
random passwords here well I can easily
guess that this is an md5 hash password
which means I can depending on the on
the strength of the password I can
decrypt online in a second using any of
the decryption tools so if I was to just
copy this right now and I wanted to know
the password let's say this wasn't even
mine this authentication token wasn't
even mine and I found the the email and
password all I needed to do was unlatch
the password I can go to md5 online talk
which is what I use a lot and I paste
that hash right in here Nate decrypt and
you can see well first of all is gonna
prompt me to enter CAPTCHA a storefront
this is this is getting really annoying
now for some reason it always does that
as you can see it's gonna [ __ ] it's
gonna find the action of course this is
this is dependent on the difficulty of
the hash and whether or not it can find
it online okay so you can see that they
display the hash and the password in
plain text which in this case was passed
one two three no of course you can
experiment with this and you can also
also experiment if for example the
authentication token that you found was
using a different encryption or a
hashing algorithm for the password is
the first thing you need to do is
identify what it's using and then you go
about decrypting it now I'm not gonna be
talking about the other parts here
because that's a bit that's a bit
advanced and you can see by default the
signature the token signature field
which means we can tamper with this
token and we can make changes to it and
we can authenticate with it because as I
said the earth view shop is is designed
to be vulnerable and this is where you
perform all of these tests okay so when
it comes down to the payload the most
important things are to look for the
status the ID and obviously if you can
get any other information in the data
section or in terms of the email and the
password that's also very important now
of course it's not very easy to get a
hold of someone's of someone's token but
you can do it but and then you are
performing the penetration test on the
token because if someone was to write in
the comment section of this video
what if all to grab the the
authentication token that belongs to
Facebook let's say had access to
someone's computer
a few seconds and I was to get the
authentication token what would I be
able to do well first of all you have to
test the security of that token and I
can guarantee you that their tokens are
going to be very well secured and
performing the penetration of the
penetration test on them will be a
different ballgame so we'll be looking
at changing them or or tampering them to
give us different types of access
be talking about HTTP attribute
attributes and cookie security
I am currently running autoshop and what
I did is I started a fresh new instance
or I unzipped a new OS blue shop that's
because I wanted to start afresh and of
course in the previous video we looked
at cookie analysis and tokens but now
we're going to look at how at the
security aspect of all these cookies are
secured and how you know how cookies are
stolen and how these can be exploited
with with with other exploits or
functionality like cross-site scripting
now you'll get to what I'm saying in a
few seconds so I have watched you shop
running and I've created the same user
and password as I did last time so it's
test at test comm that being the email
and the password is password one two
three just so you know and I'll do that
right now I'm just gonna log in as you
can see test that test comm and the
password is password one two three so
let me just log in and there you are so
I've logged in and haven't solved any
challenges so when we talk about cookie
security what do I mean well this can be
done or can be inspected really easily
now of course for this you're not going
to need any of the browser extensions or
add-ons because we'll just simply just
be inspecting the element here so if we
open inspect element and going to
storage and we go into cookies and
select the site which is on localhost
you can see that if I was to click on
for example the token and we just look
at the data you know that we can see
within the token if we go to the HTTP
only section here you can see that that
is set to false now what does that mean
well that means that we can potentially
exploit this cookie and its storage
location in the sense that it is it is
it is not secured now I'll get to why
and how this is happening in the in a
few seconds all right so if the value is
set to false it means that the cookie
can be accessed and written to now how
can one use this you know for potential
attacks or cookie cookie stealing as we
know it now if you are an advanced web
application penetration tester and you
know
or cross-site scripting you know that
usually attackers will use cross-site
scripting to steal cookies by sending
you links that then you know by sending
you links to pages on the site that that
you're already authenticated to that
have the the malicious JavaScript code
that will then send your cookie your
authentication cookie with your token
etc etc through their attack server and
from that they can then use that to
authenticate into your account it's not
common because mostly the the cookies
are usually secured now you will run
into sites that have this and this is a
very very big vulnerability in terms of
severity so if you're a bug bounty
hunter this is in the medium to low
category so not really a big exploit but
still a very very big problem that many
many you know usually I would like to
say rookie developers miss especially
when dealing with huge frameworks like
node etc I'm not gonna get too deep into
that so you can see that the HTTP only
is set to false now what does this mean
this means that we can use utilize a lot
of functionality to exploit or to
display the the token or even more to
send this the my cookie or you know my
token whatever you want to call it to on
a server or to save it alright to grab
it to steal it you know simply put so
how can we exploit this well we can use
cross-site scripting and this is
probably the most used method for this
and to do this we can simply we can use
any of the we can use the search or we
can use the contact but I like using
such because usually it is unfiltered
now when I say this I'm you know many of
you will say well most of the big sites
well I'm not talking about the big sites
the big sites obviously have to take
this into consideration I'm talking
about sites that are developed by small
teams they usually don't take this into
consideration so if I was to just type
in a simple cross let's creep ting a
script that will essentially display my
cookie right now as I'm authenticated so
to do that I'll just type in script and
for this we are using an alert here to
display to us so alert and we're going
to say document whoops
stop sorry doc you
mint dot cookie and and then we're gonna
just close the script like so so this
will display our cookie to us not really
helpful but you can imagine if we were
to have this permanently posted for
example as a post here and then whenever
we send that link to someone and they
click on it we can customize this
JavaScript code to send their cookie to
our web server and once we get their
cookie you basically know what's going
to happen there so if I hit enter to
search you can see that it's going to
display our cookie and our token and
this is extremely dangerous you might
not get the context but I'll explain it
in a second so essentially this
information can be passed and sent
anywhere across the world provided that
the that your target clinks clicks on a
link in which this this script is
executed now the question that you might
be asking yourself is well where else
can we post this in in sort of a
malicious way and I know that I sound
malicious right now but I'll also get
into how to mitigate this and again
mitigating it is really simple just set
your HTTP status or your HTTP attribute
to true or set it to on essentially
securing your cookie now you can see
that once we have this you saw in the
previous video what we could do with
such information and what info it
contains in regards to the user and how
we can we can you know cracker the
password but for now let's focus on how
this can be utilized to steal the cookie
or how attackers do it so you can also
get insight if you're a white hat so
usually I can post this in here I can
put you know I can type the script in
here but this is not it's probably not
the best way of doing it because you
essentially have to convince the user to
go into the search bar and type this in
not really the best of ways about going
you know but going about this so usually
we look for a page that that allows us
to you know to post our own stuff or to
save this to a database or to save it to
the website itself so we let's try
contact us alright so contact us yeah
that looks like a good place to start so
in the comment it's already added our
author for us so in the comment we can
enter
we can end our script in yen this will
probably probably be saved but we have
to test it now of course the cookie
stealing JavaScript code is not
something that I'm going to be telling
you how to do you can probably perform a
lot of Google searches it's part of the
easy terms that I have to follow in
regards to YouTube's
YouTube's policies about malicious
content and when what not so I'm not
going to show you the exact code but
I'll probably have it on my website if
you want to take a look at it and
experiment as to how to send cookies to
another server server that belongs to
you for example so to do this so now
essentially what I want to do is I want
to save this script into their contact
section because I believe this is saved
if I looked I looked at this structure
and indeed this is saved so this script
is quite simple so we can say we can
give it a title because I know the
feedback is is left like that so we can
say script test and we can close the
script here so script but then we have
to include the the actual JavaScript
code so yeah so let's include this
script within the main ones so script
and then once we close this one we can
then use the other script so a script
oops
script and you can copy this code if you
want by the way let me just zoom in
cause a lot of you had actually talked
to me about that that you couldn't
actually see the code so script and now
we want to bring out the alert and of
course as I said this is not really
useful because all you're doing is
displaying the cookie to the user
themselves once they visit this page so
you you you probably get the idea so
script alert and we add this simply is
gonna write the document of course if I
was sending it to a malicious server
what I would have done is out of use the
document dot cookie and I would have
offended it to be sent in in the form of
probably a PHP file or a PHP get request
to my server and then my server would
log all of the the information being
sent back so that's the concept there
behind so we can then close the script
here and
we have to actually close the script
oops sorry my bad and we closed the
script there and finally we can close
the final script ending here so script
and there we are and we can leave a
rating if we want to and there is a
CAPTCHA here or authentication 10 plus 5
you you you basically have this is also
an exploit here that you can enter
because if you look at this very
basically from a simple perspective the
capture here is again is another false
positive and again I know I'm dragging
this I'm dragging it a lot but but what
I'm trying to explain here is if you are
going to you are going to be performing
a penetration test on a website you you
need to understand that from the
perspective of false positives you
should not go after the big
exploitations or the big exploits first
alright so if I submit this as I know
this structure of the OS view shop this
will be submitted to one of the pages in
which after I click or any other user
who is authenticated clicks will will
run that script or this script and will
the the via cookie will be displayed on
their screen and if you want to
manipulate or use your own script to
send their cookie to your server
by all means go and do that I am not
condoning it so that is 75 and I hit
submit and what master on capture 10
plus 5 actually 25 yes brackets of
division multiplication addition you
guys must be thinking ahead mats so that
is 25 plus 5 plus 10 sorry that's 35 35
and I submit that oops we have to
actually type out good back in sorry
about that guys so we can just type in
script and we simply testing test and
then after this we can close the first
one and script here oops sorry about
that my keyboard is quite a distance
from me a litte and my spelling mistakes
are really annoying script and finally
we can use the document my god man by
typing document dot alert
dot cookie sorry we have already sent
the alert we would use the doc document
dot alert would essentially display the
entire webpage document dot cookie and
in here we close the first script and
sorry the the initial script and then we
close the last one here so script and we
close that right there and finally we
can give this a rating and we submit and
that should submit it I don't know what
the issue is here and there we are was
for some alright so there we are thank
you for your feedback so it did submit
it there let me zoom back out now you
can see that where would you go to
launch this script that's that that will
be the question that you might be asking
so on this in this structure you can
pretty much experiment with all the
other pages and again I do recommend
that you use you know directory
discovery tools like there buster go
bust or whatever is comfortable for you
so with this in mind if first you just
click on about us you can see that that
is where the the the feedback in regards
to contact is stored so there you are
there's the cookie and default if I was
to have implemented a script that would
send the cookie to my server once I
access to this page as an authenticated
user it would send my my session ID all
of that good stuff to my web server and
I'll be able to crack the password and
authenticate with your account as simple
as that without ever knowing your
password without ever trying to have
guessed it with or without ever trying
to have exploited your system I
exploited the web application and
because of the the inability of the
developer of the web application to
secure the cookies I was able to get
into your account and God knows what
else you can do in that person's account
and this is you know this is tribute to
all my facebook hacker friends out there
who think hacking Facebook is is about
cracking and brute 4/3 there you go you
know applications can be can be cracked
in or can be exploited in different ways
now of course I said it's gonna get
really exciting as we move along with do
shop and that's the reason I'm using it
because
it explains how this can be done on a
real website and yeah
we're going to be looking at OSP juice
shop and it seems to replicate what a
real web application would be fairly
poorly designed one but the thing I like
about it is it has varying live levels
of difficulty and that's really really
awesome I have it set up on Heroku as
you can probably see right over here and
that works perfectly fine for me because
I you know I wanted to set it up really
quickly I don't want to run it on my
local server you know using node or
docker that's really is I really didn't
have the time to do that but if you want
to you can you can use Heroku and it
should be free for you so yeah
definitely go ahead and give it a try
and you should have an instance set up
for yourself so you can go ahead and do
it and it's giving us a prompt ear
telling us that this website uses fruit
cookies to ensure you get the juiciest
tracking experience you know from my
experience I would hit accept the
cookies because essentially that's what
keeps track of your progress and yeah
that's pretty that should be quite good
now as for my browser I'm using the
latest version of Firefox and I have you
know plugins or add-ons like cookie
editor and that's pretty much what we'll
be needing in this video I hope and we
don't have the the proxies here like
sorry foxy proxy to allow us to use
things like burp suite or zap whatever
you want to use okay so let's get
started now the first challenge as I
believe is to get the scoreboard and we
should start from there and to do this I
think I have done this already that's
really very simple all we need to do is
well first of all before we actually do
that the interface is quite simple it is
a juice shop as you probably can see and
could have understood and they sell
juice now the great thing that I like
about OSU shop is that this replicates a
real-life web application with you know
security misconfigurations etc etc so if
I had log in you have your login page
right over there and you can create a
new account if you want to you can
search where they contact us page it
allows us to you know essentially
contact whoever is behind the site and
we have an about Us page and the thing I
like about this is as I said it
gates what I would call a real web
application now only took about about
three scoreboard I think that can be
accessed really quickly by going into
scoreboard like so so you know you can
just hit scoreboard and if I enter that
should give us the scoreboard all right
so it gives us the notification once
you've completed a challenge and the
reason it does this is to notify you of
your progress remember this can be
considered a capture the flag type of
challenge but I wouldn't call it this I
think this is fantastic for essentially
explaining the concepts here all right
so let me explain all these scoreboard
is definitely works alright so your
scoreboard is as follows sorry about
that if you had my phone it always seems
to do that so we have we have the
challenges sorted in terms of difficulty
so we have a 1 star 2 star 3 star 4 star
5 star and 6 star and they all have
various challenges within them so for
example the the difficulty sort in terms
of stall so you get the idea 1 star is
quite easy two stars
you know not so easy we have three stars
things are getting a bit sweaty here
four stars
now we're talking five stars I'm banging
my head on the wall and six does that's
gonna take you probably a few a few days
or you know hours depending on your
determination alright so you can see it
also gives you the gives you the
challenge names here so if I click on
the two star challenges you can go ahead
and look at the challenges there and we
provide think in the previous videos we
covered a lot of the two star and three
some of the four star challenges that's
why I wanted to go through so the three
star challenges are where things get
really awesome because it does you start
logging in with other users and there's
a bit of cross-site scripting I'm not
going to go through all of that let's
start off with what we can do all right
so the first challenge in the first is
access the administration section of the
store alright so I'm guessing we have to
try and log in I think I've done this
this is the first challenge we have to
access a confidential document provoke
an error that is not gracefully very
gracefully handled not to show that is
let us redirect you I'll try and cover
as many as I can
on video we have cross-site scripting
attack this was simple I think we
covered this so yeah we can pretty much
run that in in one of these right over
here so script and alert as it already
gives you hints these are very very easy
so you can just say test have I given
the oops sorry
my bad so yeah there we are test and we
close that up and we also close this
script right over here and we enter and
there we are so that is one of the
challenges solved hopefully it did pop
up there so if we go back to the
scoreboard it still tells us well for
some reason the web application is too
low it's not told us that we have
performed a reflected cross-site
scripting all those that don't all right
so reflected anyway we'll get to that
when we get to it so if we inspect the
login page what we can do is we can
create a user so I'm going to create a
user here and I'll just use a simple
user here called test at test comm and
the password I'll call that password and
I'm going to repeat the password here
and I'll just call the password password
and I'm just going to use name of your
favorite pet and I'm just gonna say dog
right over here I'm gonna it register
and we're gonna save that alright so I
can log in now did I log in with the
correct test yeah there we are I'm gonna
log in and we are logged in alright so
let me just zoom out so the interface
does not really crash on us let me just
get rid of that all right so it's sorted
out really well we have the language
selector here your basket which
essentially allows you to select your to
view the items in your basket you then
have your coupon if you want if you want
to use a coupon and you have your
checkout which essentially I believe
takes you to the the osu shop donate
page if i'm not wrong
let's just see if that is correct yeah
you so if you want to support the
project I would reckon donate to them
it's it's a really great project I
really do recommend that if you can you
do so so you can change your password
which is awesome I think we also took a
look at this and how to change it using
using the get requests contact us where
you can necessarily write in you can
contact the the person behind the site
or the administrator as I would believe
you can comment recycle recycle what's
this request a recycling box so you can
type in liters here that has a selector
all right okay that's not too bad we
have a complaints board and the
scoreboard itself here which for some
reason keeps doesn't really load so
let's try and work on the first section
as I mentioned I'll try and cover as
much as I can here and you have the
about us here that has some sort of
let's see some sort check out our boring
Terms of Use
let me just check the scoreboard what
exactly are we supposed to do because
access the administration section what's
in the two star here login with the
administrator all right so we're trying
to access the administration section so
let's try and access that right over
here so I'm just gonna type in
administration like so I'm gonna enter
and yeah that was pretty easy and we get
the email right over here admin and to
shop
that's the admin email and we have all
the emails right over here so we have
Jim and juice do shop bender and some
other users and we have our soap yeah
alright so we got the registered users
customer feedback and the recycling
requests that have been posted so far
which means we're starting from the
basics so I think we can try and login
with admin but we don't know the
password so yeah so I'm just gonna log
out and let's see if we can login with
the password here here admin I do shop
and I probably I'm probably guessing we
have to use SQL injection and in this
case I think I know what to do cuz I
have done this before but it has been
changed quite a bit since the last time
because I think in the previous versions
it was with admin only there was no
domain was they using him I'm not too
sure
anyway let's try and see if we can throw
some errors here so if I log in all
right so that means you have to provide
a password so let me just try and use
the single quotation and let's see if
that yeah it does throw an error and
yeah we completed the other challenge
which you successfully solve the
challenge error handling provoked an
error CF so essentially performing error
enumeration if that's something you've
never heard of it's essentially where
you just try and see how to see oh it's
fuzzing really just throwing a you know
information at a system see how it
responds and we get here the query yeah
so we are performing SQL injection
because as you can see tells us here we
have the DES query right over here which
is telling us select and what this is
saying select all entries from the user
table where emails are equal to and we
specify this single quotation and the
password is what is this this looks like
a hash what hash is this let me just
check I think it might be md5 I'm not
too sure let me just check this hash
identifier and we just paste that in
there sorry about that let me just paste
that in there yeah this is md5 hash so
that probably let's just see if we can
decrypt that or decode that so I'm just
gonna say md5 Decrypter or something
like that let's just see if we can do
this online really quickly come on come
on I want to see what error caused that
ceiling is that's a password
let's decrypt that and well for some
reason it's taking too much time here so
yeah yeah it's essentially hashing the
password alright interesting stuff there
we actually now know that the password
is being hashed obviously you know with
the md5 hashing algorithm or protocol
whatever you not call it so original and
yeah that is the query statement there
so we can try some basic SQL injection
and some of the basic ones to log in to
admin or to essentially a log into the
administration
the admin panel is now the thing that's
weird is are we going to use the
password yeah we are trying to get
authentication so that means let me just
close that that means if we just throw
the error one more time or get thee when
you able to get the query here so we are
saying select actually starts from there
select from users to select all queries
or all entries from the user table from
where email use a table so there's users
all right so the user the user table has
email and password okay I follow now so
that means we can try we can try we can
try and use The Awl statement here and
probably we can use the not statement if
we are going to yeah that will make a
lot of sense but we only using email so
we'll keep the single quotation so what
that means is is if you know about SQL
injection hopefully I can explain what's
going on here
so we know that the password is being
hashed so we're saying select from the
table where email and password so that's
the statement so select from the table
select from the users table where the
email and password is going to be equal
to is going to be equal to what we have
entered but remember the the password
has to be us to stay as the single
quotation so that means Yahweh we are
going to be using the all so this is
basic you sugar should be knowing this
but if you want me to cover it let me
know so or equals so all one equals one
and the other other ways of doing this I
think I'll post a cheat sheet in the
description section you can check it out
for yourself just to get up to scratch
with what's happening here so what we
are saying is we're using the or the or
the syntax of or is very simple it's
where we have the what's happening here
is we're saying we're saying okay so you
if you know the syntax for how a query
is made in s SQL is really very simple
so we're saying select from from the
table remember this is specifying a
table
not a column so I say select from the
users table from select from the users
table email password so a comparing and
then we say all I know is specify the
condition where the value we can enter
are in two fields so we can say the
value of the email can always be changed
and we obviously know that that is the
first account that was created and the
password is going to remain the same so
we hit login and yeah we get still keep
on getting an error here now that is
weird no because if I specify there is
no comment here or one equals one yeah
so it is working so you can see so
select from users where one equals one
and password yeah so we want to nullify
and password we don't and there so for
that we use the user comment here and
there we are excellent so we're able to
log in to the administrators user
account alright so let me explain what
happened there so as I said the the
syntax or the query was as follows so
it's selecting from the users table
we're selecting the email and password
and comparing them to each other so they
have to match so a performing a query a
simple query and what we said is or
that's a conditional statement so saying
or that we specified the condition where
the first value is going to be equal to
the the first one is it going to be
equal to 1 and we nullify the the
password where the password is so
essentially removing authentication and
we what because we're including the
comment syntax for SQL alright so that
was pretty simple but now the thing
that's bothering me is we don't have the
password so let me just check this core
body and let's see what progress we've
made so far so of access the
administration section that's not in
here that is in here so log in with the
administrators user count but I know the
password is so I think that's how we're
going to be logging in we know the email
because if I just go back into
administration here
administration I hope the video is not
getting too long so we have the admin
who have the admin email here oh yes yes
yes yes we have the token so if we
inspect the element and we go into the
Koki editor for example we can use that
or you can just use storage well I
should have done it you know from the
Koki editor from the beginning so we
have the D token here and I talked about
this in my other video actually went
through this with the token so so we're
gonna say token I think the site was
it's a JSON tokens a token decode and
should be the first site here there JSON
web tokens so JWT dot io that's an
excellent site and we talked about this
so if you want to watch that video I'll
post it in the description so you can
check it out and the email is admin so
that's the authentication token and that
gives us all the information we need all
right so we have the password here but
again what is this hashed into that
looks like md5 again but let me just
confirm and let's see what that gives us
so the password is hashed as we know is
md5 so let's just confirm hash I didn't
keep fire because they are yeah it is
md5 so let's just decrypt that one more
time
so I'm just gonna paste in that hash
there I'm just going to decrypt let's
give that a few seconds oh my god man or
the traffic lights and let's hit verify
and yeah there we have the password is
admin 1 2 3 yeah that's that's pretty
basic but again replicating common
practice that you would find so what was
the email oh boy what was the email a
meter sitting in block back crack
alright so let me just use these
statements oh yeah way so we're logging
in so all 1 equals 1 because what does
the I think we can access the the email
from the administration sorry about that
guys I know I'm getting really mixed up
we're not logged in yet so uh anyway let
me just log in and we can do the
administration here stration and the
admin I do shop at juice shop a juice op
yeah that's there to confuse people so
you can guess it and we're looking in
with that and the password is admin one
two three I'm gonna login and yeah
fantastic so you solve the challenge
password strength so that was the
problem there that that's the
vulnerability that they're trying to say
exist so you know again password
strength is something that people don't
take into account login within message
you user credentials without previously
changing them or applying in skew could
you have done this with SQL injection
probably I'll have to cover SQL
injection because me know SQL injection
is one of those things that's really
dependent on the query so let me just go
back to the scoreboard here I don't
understand what else is left there's
still a lot of stuff that I have to
cover I talked about cross-site
scripting but I think I'll cover that in
the next video we'll explain it again
what is the what is the the confidential
document error handling or we don't have
anything much their access someone
else's basket I did that what else
should I want to cover here let's look
at these ones right over here so yeah so
the authentication area here is where I
want to look at I think that's what I'm
gonna end this video I know I haven't
covered any advanced stuff but hopefully
that's like an introduction so
everywhere we have been able to log into
the administrators in the administrators
account we were able to get this
scoreboard the administration panel what
else were able to do we were able to
provoke an error not sign on nothing
really complex there and we were able to
log in with the admin trail at the
administrators user credentials now we
looks like we can actually get access to
Mac safe such original users credentials
so again another user that we can try
and get access into yeah that's going to
be it for this video guys if you found
via
in this video please leave a like down
below if you have any questions or
suggestions let me know in the comment
section on my social networks or on my
website and I'll be sure to leave your
reply and I'll be seeing you in the next
video peace guys